Okay,
boom,
boom.
We're live.
We're live with the lines,
our boat.
And he just got back spray and chem trails for the past six hours.
All Crile.
I'm Joe Southern California.
He's controlling minds and the weather.
There's a reason why it's cloudy out folks.
It's Alonzo Boden,
hilarious,
standup comedian slash weather modification experts.
What's was up,
Joe?
Nothing was going to rain tonight.
I'm just saying.
I'm just saying I can't believe it that you know,
you might want to put the top up when the convertible.
Why are you working for the man?
Hey,
it pays well,
but you make great money.
You're a comic.
You do well.
You're very successful.
I know Joe.
But you know,
ever since Obama took over,
I mean he gave me a call.
He said,
look alive,
so we need a brother on the weather.
I said,
I got you.
So this is part of that whole thing.
So it's part of like black lives matter.
I just want to let you in.
Oh,
okay.
I understand.
That makes sense.
Look,
you gotta do what you gotta do in this crazy world.
And a little weather modification is on the menu.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
then I'm kicking,
I'm getting some of the ski resort money from mammoth.
You know,
that's like a side hustle.
They say this winter is going to be fucking crazy.
The weather modification experts.
I'm just here to let you know El Nino,
do you believe in an El Nino?
But is that real?
Yeah,
I think that is,
but,
but whether,
you know what's so funny about the weather?
Like they,
they really don't know it at best it's an educated guess.
Right?
So when they say something like there's a change in an ocean current,
like that's what El Nino is,
right?
Like there's warm water flowing through the ocean where it's normally cold and
that's going to bring more water vapor.
And I get that on the large scale,
but they can never say,
okay,
it's going to rain Tuesday between noon and four o'clock.
Like th there are times when they're so wrong.
It's comical.
Like in any other job you'd be fired for being that far off and they're like,
oh,
we missed.
But compared to like how they used to be,
it's fucking amazing when they used to just look up at the sky and when there
are clouds are running well we better get inside.
That was it.
Yeah.
They knew a tornado was coming cause you could see the tornado coming like that
was a,
you know,
but,
but then you have the other things like a,
in Phoenix they have whether people,
right?
Like what is your job from April through November in Phoenix.
Yeah.
It's going to be hot zit sunny hot feedback tomorrow.
Like there's,
there's nothing else in what it in July they have oh yeah.
It's going to be monsoon.
It's going to rain between three and four men.
It's going to be hot again.
Yeah.
There's no weather.
And then La,
the same thing.
I mean,
over the summer it's occasionally you get like a little bit of rain in La.
Yeah.
What did it rain like maybe four times this year?
I,
I did a thing with,
uh,
what's his name?
The comics slash weatherman.
Uh,
Fritz Rogan.
Um,
Fred Rogan.
Fred?
No.
Or Fritz Fritz called Colmar.
It's cold.
I get him confused with that other guys here.
Oh,
that's the sports guy.
Their partners,
right?
Yeah.
I did a thing with Fritz Coleman and one of his funniest jokes.
He said,
you think it's easy doing weather in la?
think of 300 different ways to say partly cloudy in the morning,
sunny in the afternoon.
Well,
it gives you a lot of time to write jokes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Good Gig for comic.
Yeah.
Plus you get on TV if they let you plug your gigs.
It'd be in the Ice House on Tuesday.
Come on down.
I think he does well because people see the name and like when they walk into
the club,
they're like,
that's the weatherman.
You know what I mean?
Like it's an instant recognition kind of Gig.
Yeah.
But he's got to like keep it super clean,
right?
Oh yeah.
He's,
he's nice.
Yes.
If you're a weather guy or a news guy.
Oh,
and if you just,
just straight slightly outside the lines,
people are looking at take you down,
but they still do it.
That's what's funny.
Yeah.
You always hear about the,
the little small town where the guy that was in some weird thing like got caught
with a prostitute at a massage.
But you know what I mean?
Yeah,
I know,
but,
but when you know you're that guy,
then you know,
you like gave that up,
you know what I mean?
Like you,
you,
you're not allowed to do that.
You won't get crazy.
You know,
you're like,
well,
I'm going to be on TV every day so I can't,
you know,
I got to give up the hookers and blow.
Yeah.
You're not in the paid off.
Right,
right.
If you're even a comic or a comic,
yeah.
We can get busted.
Yeah.
And just you now you have a new bit,
like you can't exactly hymns.
Exactly.
I can't think of that.
I don't know what a comic could do.
I guess violence would be the only thing unforgivable for a comic.
But when it comes to like sex scandals or you know,
cheating on your wife or,
or drunk at the airport or whatever,
like for comics,
they're like,
yeah,
well just makes it better.
He's
more,
more material like looking at Kat Williams,
look at Kat Williams,
last special half of the special was all this shit that he got arrested for over
the last two years.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that,
that's a trip.
Like I worked on this cruise line and they said,
yeah,
cat came,
but he had a gun.
And you're just like,
what?
You brought a gun to a cruise ship?
Like what?
What did you expect to happen on a cruise ship?
You know what I mean?
Like maybe somebody could throw him off.
That's what freaked me out about a crew shot.
Somebody throwing you off because that has happened.
Like some guy through his wife off and he's like,
oh,
I don't know what happened.
She was young,
she went out to get a drink and then,
uh,
well,
and they were like,
what?
It was like the reaction the guy had to his wife falling over more,
the crocodile tears and they were like,
okay dude,
how was he?
This is a question.
So how,
how will you,
and Debbie,
how are you guys getting along?
You know,
I guess fight a lot.
I do these charter cruises,
jazz cruises and stuff,
and you know,
after the cruise,
the guy who runs it will tell some of the funny stories of what happened while
we were at sea and on one cruise,
newlyweds get into a fight the first night she threw all of his clothes
overboard,
everything of his thrown overboard dad to bring him to the ship's store and he
had to wear,
you know,
they sell like the little shorts and Polo shirts from the cruise line and he had
to wear that all week.
Well,
I hope he stayed with her,
I hope.
Yeah.
I don't know how it worked out in the long run.
The crews little throwing clothes overboard.
I hope it didn't wreck a beautiful future relationship.
Beautiful matrimony,
beautiful nuptials in the Lord's eyes.
You had to know that was in her though,
right?
You'd never know,
man,
I've,
I've met people that got married and then immediately afterwards there checked
became a nightmare.
Really?
Yeah.
I've heard that more than I've heard.
I don't know.
I've heard some things but not,
but like to that extent I would think that'd be flashes of psycho prior to that
level.
I don't know.
My Buddy said when his girl got pregnant,
like she was a little irritable because you know she was pregnant,
but he said,
but then after the baby came like the whole,
once she realized that he was never going to leave,
cause he loves the baby and he loves,
he loves that,
you know,
having a family.
She just started ordering them around,
yelling at him,
barking orders on and telling him what he can and can't do now.
And he was like,
what the fuck happened to you?
Like we're the same people.
We just have a baby now.
But in your mind,
no,
the relationships change.
We're going to have to reorganize and restructure this deal.
We're going to have to sit down and uh,
this is how it's going to go.
Now I'm ready to go.
See your mouth is time to renegotiate and you have no negotiating power in this
negotiation.
She kept threatening to take the kid away.
That was her big thing.
Take the kid away.
I'm gonna move in with my parents,
like all kinds of crazy shit,
man.
Yeah.
And just immediately,
and he,
he went from being like the happiest guy.
I'm sighing.
She's perfect.
We get along so well.
We're going to have a baby together.
There's going to be amazing too.
Fuck Dude.
I don't know what to do.
Fuck.
Like he was just constantly stressed down.
His eyes were darting around the room and yeah.
That,
that sounds like the old days when you had to stay married,
right.
That,
that was our parents' generation.
They stayed married.
They hated each other.
I'm not saying specifically,
but you know what I mean,
like that divorce,
they just didn't do it.
They just stayed married.
They would like,
yeah,
we've been married for 50 years.
Don't particularly like each other,
but,
uh,
we gotta stay married because we made a vow,
you know?
I mean,
that,
that's how it was.
It was a generational pressure.
And now they say the opposite is true.
Like you have one bad day.
Yeah.
It's enough of this shit.
Well,
it's a religious thing too,
right?
You know,
like a lot of people don't want to get like Catholics especially did not want to
get divorced.
That was a big thing.
Yeah.
It was like the like an unforgivable sin.
When I was young that was a big deal,
man.
Someone talk about but getting divorced,
I remember when I was a little kid,
like a lot of it was like they would start bringing up the church about the
church doesn't want you to getting divorced.
You know in the eyes of the Lord you're married,
you should work this out and you don't,
part of the problem is who you are when you meet.
Say If you meet your 25 you know you fall in love,
you get married and you're 30 who you are at 30 is not who you are at 40 you
will,
you are a different fucking human being but you have a much better chance then.
Then really young,
like I have a niece,
she's 26 and she's engaged and I'm still waiting to see how this plays out
because he's 23 and I'm just like too young like you know it because just think
who you are at 23 to who you are at 30 completely different totally though.
So it's like if you grow up together,
that's cool.
And you,
you know,
you go through those bumps together but it's too easy to be like a whole
different person.
I mean when I moved out here,
when I came to La I,
I worked uh,
an aircraft so I went to aviation high school in New York.
Lockheed aircraft discovered this high school that trains airplane mechanics.
So they literally hired hundreds of us like move to La,
you got a job.
I knew more guys 18 and 19 who married their girlfriend cause they didn't want
to like they will leave at home,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm starting life,
we're going to get married.
Consequently,
I knew more guys who were divorced at 21
I would imagine my girlfriend in high school,
my my eight when I was 18,
I would have definitely married her really 100%.
How long you think it would last a week?
A couple of months at the most sheet.
She was a very nice girl,
but uh,
she moved across town,
uh,
not across town.
Across the state,
like an hour and a half away and just,
I was so sad.
I couldn't believe it.
God Damn saw the way over there.
If she wanted to get married and we would be together,
I would have done it.
I will say without exaggeration,
without exaggeration of a hundred guys I knew married before they were 20.
I only know two.
Still buried.
I only know 200 guys got married.
But they were,
yeah,
guys were coming out and it was like their fruit.
Like I got a job,
I got an apartment,
let me send from my girlfriend from New York.
Wow,
let's get married.
And they were just doing it.
There were two things that we did on a regular basis.
Go to weddings and bail guys out of jail cause everybody was getting Duis,
you know,
so it's like,
we were like,
all right,
let's just keep a Dui Fund for whoever gets picked up this week.
You guys end up fund.
We practically did.
We,
we had a network where we call like,
yeah,
so and so's in jail.
All right,
I got 50 bucks.
I got 100 bucks,
whatever.
And we get good amount.
Yeah.
How much does it cost to get
you out of jail for a Dui back then?
Let's see.
That was early eighties.
Probably about four or 500 bucks.
And it wasn't,
it wasn't,
yeah.
Back then it wasn't yet the big crime.
It is now like back in around,
this is 80,
81,
82 getting a DUI was like a really bad ticket,
but they didn't,
you know,
you went to jail for one night,
but it wasn't like it is now where you,
you know,
now it's,
it's uh,
it was a matter of fact,
I taught comedy traffic school and what the late nineties,
and they said a Dui then costs you 10,000 bucks by the time you paid for the
fine and drunk driving school and a lawyer and all of that,
it's gotta be a lot more than that now.
It's probably 10 to 15 pedals,
a big crime now crime.
When I was in high school,
a kid I went to school with,
Nice Kid,
uh,
gotten a drunk driving accident,
killed his friend.
Never forget that.
That's,
I think that's the worst part.
If you,
if you have that because you gotta live with that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And I can't imagine it's bad enough if you have an accident,
but if you're drunk and you have an accident or you kill your friend in the car
or some shit like that,
having to live with that,
it's gotta be the worst.
Yeah.
And he was like,
I don't think we're any older than 17 or 18 at the time.
I think he was just learning how to drive really.
And,
um,
I heard about it,
heard the whole story and I knew that he had tried to commit suicide in the
hospital.
He tried to jump out the window.
The cops told him they came up to him while he's in the hospital bed and said,
you know,
you're a murderer now.
And he's like,
what?
He's like,
your friend's dead.
You're a murderer now.
Yeah.
And he's like,
what,
what?
And he just freaked out and he just ran towards the window and they grabbed him
and I was walking down the street in my neighborhood and,
uh,
he was walking towards me and I saw him and he saw me and we looked at each
other and I said,
how you doing man?
I said,
hi,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'll never forget the sadness.
The sadness was oozing out of his body.
Good.
They had this bastard,
they had this commercial and it was like the last text of people who died
texting.
Did you ever see that one?
No,
but there was a guy,
I think he was
publicists to a Paris Hilton or something like that.
Like one of those,
like,
I think it was Paris.
Hilton's publicist drove off the fucking mountain in Malibu.
You know that that was a crazy winding roads and he was a,
he made a text about his dog,
like,
lol,
she's so cute.
I like the dog was in the car with him
fucking off that for,
I forget the specific to the case,
but they found the dude at the bottom of the canyon and then they deduced like,
oh,
this dumb fuck was was texting one single passenger.
I mean a dog by himself,
not an accident and didn't collide with anything.
Just went off the side of off the,
yeah.
Well I,
it's,
I dunno,
they'll never have them.
You'll never
had me on the podcast again.
People like this.
The sad as shit I've ever heard a lot sadder.
We're 10 minutes in and everyone's dying.
Well,
you don't think when you're driving and you're drunk,
especially,
you don't think it's going to happen to you.
That's,
that's the real [inaudible].
Everyone thinks it's,
everyone thinks that someone else I can drive.
I'm okay.
Well,
that's what alcohol does to you though.
Alcohol has you convinced that everything's going to be fine.
Yeah.
You hold all of your perceptions off so you think it.
Yeah,
I'm all right.
Which is like the exact opposite of pot.
When you smoke pot,
you're like,
I can't fucking drive,
dude.
There's no way I can drive like drive.
When you're high,
everything works like you can hit the brakes.
You can make turns,
but you're convinced that there's no fucking way you're going to be able to make
this exit.
The exit's over there.
I got to get over there.
Fuck.
I remember one of the first times I ever drove when I was high.
I just couldn't believe I was driving.
I was like,
this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Meanwhile,
I was going 55 miles an hour,
staying in the lane was very aware of everything.
Looking left,
looking right,
looking in the rear view mirror.
But if I was drunk I'd been like,
I got this guy wouldn't,
when I used to get loaded,
I could drive high.
I never liked to be a drunk cause I always felt out of control.
You know,
just let,
not like crazy out of control but sloppy out of control.
He wants terrible drug.
Yeah.
So especially the next morning when you wake up sober in jail or you realize
what you did,
that's when it hits.
Have yet DUI before.
No,
Nah.
Knock Wood.
Got Arrested for possession once.
That's when I got sober.
Really got arrested for possession of cocaine to dude who spent a night in jail
and a,
and I'm going to tell you the happiest moment in court is when,
when you show up for your possession of cocaine and as a public defender and I'm
sweating,
like I don't know,
like what's going to happen or,
or this or that because it was crack that you know,
I had.
So I'm like,
and he's like,
you okay?
I'm like,
Eh.
He said,
did anyone tell you no?
oh,
whatever you had,
it wasn't cocaine.
So you're just here on driving on a suspended license.
I was like,
guilty.
Guilty.
What?
Suspended license out.
Someone's telling you some bullshit crack.
Thank God.
Wow.
What was it?
Uh,
who knows?
I don't know what it was.
Whatever it was.
When they tested it,
it was not cocaine.
I'll tell you what it was.
It was the greatest day of my life.
He,
Joey Diaz would tell stories about giving girls chopped up aspirins and them
acting like it's the greatest coke they've ever done in their life.
Yeah.
People,
well,
so much of it is like psychological but with,
but with crack,
I mean when it hits you,
you know it,
but this one,
I listen,
Joe,
I got busted.
It was the dumbest thing.
Like,
uh,
I was on this street,
you know,
crack road,
whatever you,
you go to cop.
Right.
So I had the rock and I knew to rock because I had tried to smoke it and it
melted.
And I was like,
does it bullshit?
So I go back,
like I'm looking for the guy,
right?
Like what am I going to do?
I ain't gonna do shit.
Like I'm not hard.
You know what I mean?
I'm not a Crip,
I'm just going back looking for the guy and the cop swooped on the street and
they come in from both sides with cars,
you know,
like it's a whole thing to shut down the whole street.
So I throw the rock out of the window.
It hits the gutter above the window and lands in my lap.
When the cop,
I had a rock my lap,
it's like I tried to get rid of,
you know how you think a cut like a rock.
If your windows open a rock,
you can just flick it like a bugger.
That's what I thought.
He tried to throw it out the side window passenger.
No,
no.
Drivers bounced off.
Literally hit that gutter or you know that little rail above the window and
bounced right.
Landed right in my lap to daddy's shit.
Luck man.
Great lucky.
Great luck in the long run.
But in the moment,
not good.
Wow.
So Dan was the moment you decided to quit when I,
yeah,
that night in jail.
It was one of those things where like it's one of those moments where you
realize I'm not supposed to be here.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like with everything that had transpired in my life,
like I was still in aerospace then,
but you know,
licensed airplane mechanic,
good job,
blah,
everything else.
It just hit me in that moment.
Like this is not how it's supposed to end because I knew guys who had gone down
that road,
you know what I mean?
Like I knew guys who were doing time and shit like that.
And,
and for a lot of guys,
jail is just part of life.
You know what I mean?
Like I go away for a couple of years,
come back,
like I'm not that guy.
You know what I mean?
And I didn't want to,
I didn't want to become that guy.
I had no aspiration when I was a kid that one of the neighbors' sons,
he was in Attica,
and I will never forget this.
We were going somewhere upstate New York and we went to visit him.
And when you go in and that gate closest behind you,
like I don't know if you've ever been in a maximum security prison,
but when that gate,
it's
toluene never forgot that sound for the rest of my was like,
oh fuck no.
They say whatever I do,
this ain't where I'm going to end up.
Where did he go to Attica for a robbery.
Armed robbery.
Yeah.
He was in the armed robbery.
He was a,
he was a habitual criminal.
He'd spent the rest of his life.
He was never out of jail for more than a year.
Because once you get in that system,
then you're always getting picked up for something.
So,
and the people that you know and the people that you surround yourself with,
it becomes a pattern that you're constantly around.
People that are doing things like that.
It becomes normal.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
It becomes normal.
And,
and once it becomes normal,
it's,
it's tough to crack.
So how old were you when you first tried crack?
Uh,
let's see.
Speaking of tough to crack 22,
maybe 23,
something like that.
And what was the scenario?
Uh,
well actually the first time I tried,
okay.
It started out,
you know,
like just party and as a kid smoking weed,
uh,
drink a beer,
whatever,
and then get into a little cocaine
here and there,
you know,
um,
snorting it.
And then I had a friend and this had to be [inaudible] 84,
maybe 83,
whatever,
when people were still just starting to get into freebase and,
and crack and stuff like that.
And he hit it and he gave me the pipe and I hit it and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And I was like,
it scared me.
I was like,
this is too good.
Like I said,
man,
you better.
You better get off this shit.
This is gonna like you're gonna lose everything.
Wow.
Cause the high was so good,
you know?
And what does it feel like?
Describe it?
Uh,
it's a rush.
It's an overpowering rush of energy and I don't,
I don't know,
like a lightning bolt hitting you with no pain but,
but just like,
like you're,
you're buzzing.
Like your whole body is just,
you know,
I guess cocaine works on whatever the,
um,
the receptors of good feelings and your,
I forget what it's called me scientifically,
it's dopamine,
but they're also like nerve during nerve endings that make you feel good and
cocaine works on these and,
and crack is such,
such an intense hit.
It's like doing it all at once and as opposed to when you're snorting it,
you're getting high a little here a little bit.
Now it's concentrated and it's a,
it's a rush but it,
but it's beyond anything else.
It is,
it is instantly addicting.
It is because it's a rush that you've never felt before any or whatnot.
I've never shot up so I can't compare it to shooting drugs.
But it,
I had never felt anything like that and it literally scared me.
And then like a year and a half later is when I got into doing it myself,
you know,
with some other guys.
And it was like me and this other guy,
we kind of said we're going to watch each other.
You know what I mean?
So it's like,
like he'll tell me when to stop or I'll tell him when the state,
and it actually worked for as long as we were both in the same room,
you know?
But then so you decided to be like sitters for each other?
Yeah.
With cause you knew because you,
cause we'd seen people,
we've seen people get sprung and lose everything.
The first guy who,
who turned me on to it,
I watched him lose,
he had this incredibly beautiful girlfriend.
She dumped him.
Then he lost his card and he lost his apartment.
Like it literally crack.
We'll take,
you know,
I mean,
Richard Pryor's jokes like that shit is true to pipe would tell you that ain't
shit.
You and me,
it's you and me.
You Ain't,
you don't need this bitch.
You don't need that fucking car.
You don't need,
you know,
I,
I sold a crack car,
I sold a car I had for five bucks,
you know,
to,
to smoke that up.
How often were you smoking at the end?
I was,
I was daily.
As much as often as I could get the money daily.
Yeah.
As,
as often as I could get.
I still had a job almost to the end,
you know what I mean?
And I got laid off from my job,
so when I got my paycheck,
that's when it would start and it,
and it was always the same bullshit.
Like,
all right,
I'm only going to do like one eight ball.
I mean,
that's like,
it's been 150 bucks that's going to be it,
you know?
So you get that and then you smoke that up,
you're like,
all right,
I'm on gone 20 more like I'm only gonna do 20 more.
I'm only gonna do 20 more.
And then you,
you do that and then next thing you know,
it's all,
it's the next day and it's all gone and the money's gone.
And,
and I was,
like I said,
I'm not a criminal.
Like I didn't come from that.
That's where my head was.
My,
my next stop was,
okay,
how do I steal something or rip somebody off or whatever.
Wow.
And um,
yeah,
it's totally,
I'm,
but,
but the bad thing is once you get to that point,
you're not getting high anymore because your brain's so fried that the drug's
not working,
like whatever the,
the nerves and need the brain cells and stuff are fried.
So you're smoking it,
but you're not getting that,
that rush anymore.
You're chasing it,
you want it,
but you can't find it.
So the initial rush that you get,
the first time you do it,
it's just overwhelming.
And then everything else has to diminish his more and more never,
you know,
like,
like shot a song.
It's never as good as the first time that,
that,
that's what,
and that's the whole thing with drug addiction.
With any drug.
It's so good that first time that you're chasing it and you can't get that feel.
And again,
I think that's the difference between addicts and regular people.
Like regular people.
Like you get high and you're like,
okay,
I'm good.
You know,
I'm a high,
um,
I'm in jail.
I'm having a good time,
but it said that,
but,
but when you're an addict it's like you want that ultimate feeling that you got
that one time and you will,
you'll sacrifice everything to get it.
Yeah.
I've never fucked with coke.
I don't know.
I don't know what that feeling is it coke in general is an up drug.
It ups your energy and a heightened sense of awareness.
That's why like you get coke,
paranoia.
Like I had coke bugs one time cook bugs,
coke,
the crawling on you.
It feels like something's crawling in your skin and you're scratching.
But people have cut themselves open.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Could but,
but I'll never forget that.
That was the weirdest thing cause it literally felt like there were bugs
crawling out of my skin and I'm just like,
ah.
You know,
and um,
but it does that like,
cause it affects your nervous system.
And this is the extreme.
This is beat.
This isn't the,
you know,
snort coke would a chick in the bathroom of a club.
You know,
that this is beyond that.
this is beyond the fun part.
Did the snorting grab you as much as the smoking or was smoking it?
We're really good.
A snorting was,
the snorting was good,
but snorting is also hard on you.
Like your nose gets fucked up.
And you know,
in the,
in the 80s there were a lot of deviated septums and there were a lot of plastic
surgeons putting noses back together in the 80s.
But what eats through your nose?
Is that true?
It literally each three.
If that was true,
yeah,
that's center membrane goes away and you know,
it just becomes one big nostril and probably better for cardio.
Yeah.
What day you go,
oh,
I used to work out,
man,
I used to get coked up and work out at a 24 hour gym.
Eh,
if I wasn't in shape,
my heart would have exploded with somebody.
Shit I used to do.
But you do it for the rush cause you're coked up and then you start lifting and
you know how it is.
You get that pump and now you're like that and you just feel like you can
fucking explode,
you know.
And,
um,
my,
I'm sure my heart was doing 150 beats a minute late.
You were coked up lifting weights.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That,
and that was one of the reasons I think that I was able to hide it because I
didn't look like a crackhead cause I didn't lose weight cause I,
I,
I got coked up and worked out.
So
I ate when I wasn't on it.
I didn't eat when I was on it,
but I ate when I wasn't on it.
So,
uh,
you were doing it every day?
Yeah.
But well,
every day is,
as long as I had the money,
the money would run out.
So if I got paid Thursday,
every day lasted til Saturday,
maybe Sunday.
And then you just get a little chip here in that little piece,
but nothing to keep your high all day.
So I mean I,
I did,
I did a lot to hide it.
You know,
I led this dual life.
Like I worked during the day and I was the airplane mechanic and then when I got
off work,
I just lock myself up in my apartment coke.
I lived like that for
my life was fully like that for a little over a year.
But the,
but the worst part,
the last two years was when it,
when it was bad,
it was bad.
So you went crazy for a year or you just dude,
what you drink and just try to calm your heart to know you drink because first
of all you,
your torch was um,
a little cotton ball dipped into one 51 rum.
Oh,
so you had one 51 there.
So you would drink that cause you have it and you drink torch.
Yeah.
And then other words like you didn't,
you don't cook crack with a lighter,
you know,
I hate giving crack lessons.
Please do on the podcast.
But no,
you don't hope you don't hold the lighter.
You need a torch.
You needed like a hotter flame.
So you would take,
and I'm trying to remember
how we did it.
Um,
I'm trying to remember what you dipped into the rum and it's great that I don't
remember.
Cause I remember the screen.
Was this a chore boy,
which was like a steel wool but no soap in it.
That's what you used as a screen in the pipe.
But that,
I forget how I did the torch,
but anyway,
the torch you would dip it into one 51 rum and light that because that was a
hotter than using a lighter.
Whoa.
But
yeah,
they came out with those,
they came out with a torch lighters later.
But like you knew certain crackhead things and you would like when you were at a
crackhead liquor store,
you know what I mean?
They,
you could tell by stuff they sold.
Like they would just have shore boy scrub brushes and they would have like one
51 rum,
but like in,
in half pints,
you know,
know who's buying a half pint out at one 51 you know what I mean?
And uh,
you get bic lighters,
you get that pack of five cause you'd go through lighters all the time.
So you just,
you,
but that was,
that was it.
That was the life.
But it was the,
it was the initial rush man.
The rush was like,
and once you hit it,
once you hit that,
then nothing else mattered.
You know what I mean?
Like in,
in other words,
once you got that first hit,
then you didn't care about and that's,
that's why you hear about those stories about people you know,
leaving the tragic stuff,
leaving their kid in the car while they are in the crack house or you know,
the guy who never comes home or whatever because you are out of your,
mind.
You,
it took over.
There were,
there wasn't very rarely did you come across a social crack user crack dominated
life.
Uh,
what,
what you saw,
what you saw happened to Chris Rock and new Jack City.
That was it.
That was real.
And that's how it was done.
That's how it would take you over.
It's amazing that you kicked it just from one arrest.
Well,
uh,
again,
that one arrest.
What?
Well,
you got to remember your hate yourself while you're doing it.
You're not enjoying it.
You know,
you're,
you're in a place cause you know you're fucking up.
You know,
I'm a,
I mean,
like in my case,
I'm not going,
uh,
my family's in New York where I grew up.
I'm not going home to visit anybody.
I'm not going home on any holidays.
I,
uh,
my last Thanksgiving now,
I mean,
I'm invited to at least two,
three friends and families,
you know,
come over for Thanksgiving dinner,
this or that.
It's me,
the pipe and,
and identities take out Thanksgiving dinner,
you know what I mean?
And you're sitting there and you know that that's what fucks with you,
you know,
and you're like,
well,
one more hit and then I'm to go to,
you know,
so and so's house,
I'm going to make it out the house today and you don't,
and,
and then,
and this is every week and it's in your mind.
Like,
I just did it again.
I didn't show up for this.
I didn't show up for that.
I'm missing work,
whatever.
I'm not,
pay bills aren't paid.
You know,
I went through bankruptcy the whole bit.
And so,
you know,
you're destroying your life.
And so the arrest was just like the,
the,
when it all came to a head,
you know what I mean?
Cause it now I'm just in jail by myself sitting in Van Nuys jail with nothing
but nothing.
But my thoughts of this is how,
this is what I did.
Yeah.
They say that you need a rock bottom,
right?
Yeah.
It's different for,
it's different for everybody,
but you that bottom.
And the only thing I remembered after that when I went to rehab was I never want
to feel like that again.
You know,
like whatever,
whatever happens in my life,
I don't want to feel like that again.
Wow.
So bad timing on the Rehab.
That's a good rock bottom though to good rock bottom story too.
It's a real rock bottom.
But when it comes to rehab,
if I had walked out of the house on last comic,
standing into celebrity Rehab,
how fucking famous would I be now?
Joe?
Pretty famous.
Yeah,
I blew it.
He timed it more timing.
When did you start doing stand up?
Well,
that's the funny thing.
And it's literally one of those cases where the worst thing in your life leads
to the best thing in your life.
So I go to Rehab.
Um,
and when you're in re I was in outpatient,
so you're in these meetings and there's psychologists and whatever.
And so it was,
this was in court appointed.
This was like your own decision?
My thing.
Yeah.
Cause I had gone when I had my job,
I had tried rehab once and I didn't make it,
cause I didn't give a shit,
you know,
so I went back to the same place and they let me back in.
So four hours a day you're doing the psychology thing and the meetings and
whatever else.
And this woman came in and she,
she was from the people who are in recovery go to rehabs and they tell people
like this is how it works,
this is what it's like,
blah blah blah.
So she was hot as all I remember is she was hot as hell,
you know,
and she was from New York.
Right.
So,
so after she talks,
I make my move,
you know,
cause I'm sober like three fucking days.
Right.
So,
but she said,
listen,
I'm married but there are a lot of women like me to go to a place called studio
12 and studio 12 was a rehab for the crew.
So the stars went to Betty Ford.
But the crew that the electricians,
the lighting guys,
the makeup artists,
the clothes,
they all went to this place called studio 12 and that's where she was from.
So she took me over there and I met these guys and I started going to meetings
there and I got,
that's where I got sober.
Those were the guys who helped me,
who showed me,
who I sponsored me with everything else.
But they were also,
they were in the entertainment business and,
and I always had a sense of humor.
I could make people laugh,
but I had never thought about it.
Cause if you're not like,
you know,
I grew up in blue collar home and then you,
you grow up,
you go to school,
you get a job,
like entertainment show business,
nowhere on the radar.
That's something that other people do and you watch on TV.
But now I know guys who were in it,
I know people who are doing it.
And I was teaching aerospace and making people laugh and shit like that.
And I said,
I want to be a comic.
And my AA sponsor was like,
man,
go for it,
try it.
And it,
and I literally did one of those writing classes and I did the five minute
graduation hooked and from then on that,
so that's how my comedy career started.
So it was it a writing like a sandy shore type class and it was a,
a guy named Len Ostvich,
he to write for rich Jenny.
Whoa.
And he was um,
he was in somewhere in Santa Monica.
They would,
they used to be a theater in Santa Monica where they used to do,
uh,
I forget what it was,
this comedy central half hour comedy thing,
I forget what it was called,
but,
but anyway,
he used to work there and that's where he did the class.
So I did the,
I did his six week writing class and a five minute graduation show.
And,
and just absolutely knew it.
Like I was like,
this is what I'm going to do.
Like I'm never going to fix an airplane again.
I'm doing this.
And,
and uh,
then,
you know,
that's how it started.
Then it was just open mikes and grinding and everything else.
And uh,
I know a lot of dudes who got into it because they would go to Aa and then
they'd have those meetings and they go up in the meetings and they would tell
funny stories about shit they did when they were fucked up.
Yeah.
I mean,
I got laughs in meetings,
but it was,
it was almost unintentional.
It was just like,
I'm telling a story,
but it's coming out funny.
Like I'm not trying to be funny.
Right,
right.
It just comes out that because you know how it is,
if you have a sense of humor when you tell a story,
it's going to be funny,
but I didn't know what I was doing,
you know what I mean?
It was just,
I had this sense of humor and what recovery did,
it changed my sense of humor from like this,
this anger,
belittling,
ripping on people thing to jokes.
Like I'm in on the joke,
like now it's just funny,
like instead of being an attack,
oh,
so before when you were doing coke,
it was like aggressive,
like angry at everybody.
This guy,
because you're paranoid and you're fucked up and,
and when you do talk to people or whatever,
you're just kind of separate from him,
you know?
And uh,
but anyway,
yeah.
So that,
that literally it had I not gotten sober,
I wouldn't have become a comic.
I don't think.
Jamie,
can you throw some tea on?
I don't know what the fuck is going on in my throat,
but I know that people listening to this probably like,
we stopped fucking clear on your throat.
I can't,
I can't help her folks.
Um,
I think it might,
you might have gone a little heavy with the grass fed butter and today's coffee.
I don't know.
Maybe that's it,
but I'm never tried to butter in coffee.
I heard it's better.
It's better than sugar.
Try some,
you might start Fleming up to maybe some of my age.
I don't know.
But um,
for me,
uh,
when I was starting out,
when I was an open mic or if there was a lot of guys,
there was a guy named Dave Fitzgerald who was a really funny guy.
And uh,
he was,
he just,
his whole life he was just doing blow and partying and drinking and fucking up.
And then he finally got himself cleaned up,
uh,
started,
um,
going to meetings and then started making people laugh at these meetings.
And he was a,
he was a good writer,
man,
a funny comic.
And then he got sick.
He got sick one.
I'm dying of cancer.
He would've been,
he would've been a big comic.
He would have made it.
He had a real good sense of humor.
He's a funny dude,
but,
uh,
just the toll on his body all those years and years of just fucking hitting it
hard.
I got,
I have friends who that's happened to mainly guys who shot drugs who like gave
him up and then 20 years later Hep c or something like that.
Like some,
some latent result from shooting drugs in her twenties destroys their body in
their fifties.
Yeah.
That have seen one's a real pump.
Real common one for guys who do heroin.
Yeah.
That was what,
um,
the Tommy Lee,
Pam Anderson accusation,
right?
It was,
yeah.
Cause they got tattoos together with the same needle to show their love.
Yeah.
Who's,
who's a tattoo artist.
It doesn't,
I don't know someone that loves Hep C,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know a tattoo like I know tattoo artists,
like if you asked him to do they beat,
uh,
no.
Like,
no,
I don't.
The gloves they did.
This is,
this is,
uh,
this is a real procedure.
You know,
it's funny that you said that you,
you grew up in a blue collar house and that you didn't know like entertainment
was never on the radar because I think that's the case for a lot of people that
once you're around someone,
like when you're around those people that were working in show business,
you're like,
oh these are just regular people.
Like this is a job.
Yeah,
it's real.
That's the case with a lot of things,
isn't it?
It's all absolutely.
Uh,
we were talking about this the other day,
we were talking about race car drivers,
right?
Cause a lot of drivers,
their kids,
their father was a race car driver.
So to them that's normal.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but,
but to most people,
the idea of driving a car to 150,
200 miles an hour,
they out Yada your mind.
But like if you grow,
but if your dad did it,
then you start driving go karts when you're like three years old.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And then you grow up and you do it and it's,
you never think about like,
this is unusual.
Did you see that movie?
Um,
with Thor?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Rush rush for forever.
I don't even know his name and some bastard.
I love it.
I love that stuff.
Formula One racing.
He,
that's the real racing,
right?
Shit is his neck.
I mean it's a whole different world,
but it's like so cool to be one of those guys like the world champion now to
Scott Lewis Hamilton out of England.
Like this guy makes $30 million a year.
He's got a private jet.
I think his girlfriend was like the leader of the spice girls or something like
that for awhile.
You know what I mean?
And he,
he flies his private jet to Malibu to see his girlfriend.
And then they always show him like hanging out at some award show.
Like he,
he knows everybody.
They were like,
he's in the Hamptons with Jamie Foxx.
You're like,
hell yeah.
Like that's,
that's how you're supposed to screw all that.
I'm training all at,
I like this guy's living life.
You know,
you're like 30 years old and you're kicking it in the Hamptons with Jamie Foxx
and banging the leader of the spice girl.
Fuck yeah,
that's,
that's a world champion.
That's Russian gas car.
This,
that
you ain't drinking PBR.
Yeah.
The Nascar thing,
I'm,
I mean,
I understand that people enjoy it and I bet it's fun as hell.
But that whole going left,
I can't,
I can't watch a race where you only go left.
I'm just can't watch.
I couldn't 500 miles of the left.
I was turning left.
Well,
there's a girl in there too.
Yeah.
Babette yeah.
And the Danica Patrick coming.
Are there other girls?
Jamie,
maybe one other room.
The knock on Danica Patrick.
And it is true.
It's like she ain't gonna win and she has an attitude about it.
It's like she did all the go daddy,
you know,
to bikini stuff and this and that.
And then she's like,
well,
why do you treat me like a girl selling bikini pictures like you?
You know,
I don't think there's anything,
you know,
people will say there's something that the,
there's like it lessens a girl to sell herself in bikinis or something like
that.
I think that is total bullshit.
I know my take on it a girl's body,
like when a girl has a hot body like keys for a guy that is the most desirable
thing to look at on the planet.
When you see a girl like,
like it has like Jennifer Lopez,
his ass,
you know that little thin waist and big ass and like good luck.
Like there was a girl in line to take pictures with us after the show,
the House of Blues in Houston and me and Ian Edwards talked about her every 20
minutes for the rest of the weekend.
Oh yeah.
Oh No,
I'm not.
This waste leg is like your arm.
And then came and it was insane.
It was insane.
And we would be,
we would be in the car and I would go that it just didn't seem like a real body.
And he goes,
it didn't seem like a real body was like,
what the fuck,
man,
I'm not knocking her for doing it.
This is my thing.
Don't do it.
And then complain when people talk about it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like in other words,
Jennifer Lopez can never say,
why aren't you looking at my ass?
Well,
Jen,
you call it j Lo,
you called us said,
look at that ass and I'm just playing alone.
A lot of them,
they started out,
they start out trying to sell it that way and then they want to be taken
seriously.
Right?
Yeah.
That does happen.
But come on,
you can still be taken seriously if you're in your underwear.
Who gives a shit?
Yeah.
Just admit that that's what you're selling.
Like you're,
it's part of you.
It's not all of you,
but it's part of you.
It was,
you know,
it story I loved.
They went to the,
um,
women,
uh,
beach volleyball players and they said,
you know,
you don't have to wear bikinis.
You can change the uniform.
And all of them were like,
no,
no.
We were wearing the Bikini's cause they knew that they were like,
yeah,
we want people to watch if we're wearing sweats.
Nobody's watching beach volleyball.
So I remember a knock when I first started doing comedy especially,
I always was like real nervous about people seeing the fact that I had muscles
seeing the fact that it worked out because I always felt like that working out
and comedy word,
they just didn't go together.
No Way.
You couldn't,
you couldn't have,
you couldn't be built right.
And do stand up,
you know.
But then I met guys like you and then I met Nick Depaulo was the first one I met
Nick Dipaolo in Boston does back when he was young.
He used to play football players,
big giant neck fucking,
and he was killing.
Yeah.
And I was like,
this is bullshit.
All you have to do is just be funny.
Yeah.
To hide it.
Early in my career I used to acknowledge it.
I've stopped even acknowledging it,
but it's always funny to me when people are like,
man,
if they don't laugh,
you could just beat him up.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's my second strategy.
That's what we do.
That's,
that's absolutely what I was going to do because I'm a fucking Viking and I'm
just going to jump into the crowd and start beating the shit out of this is
funny.
Yeah.
The idea that uh,
somehow or another like a person who's fit or you have a good body or something
that that precludes you from being smart.
Like that's a big thing with girls.
Like if a girl is a hot body,
thinks she's gotta be a fucking idiot instantaneously you see grown in the
beginning a bikini with a nice body,
a good percentage of the population wants to write her off because it's an easy
ride for her.
Cause if,
cause we know that if you are built like that,
the odds that you're doing the work,
the odds that you're really studying shit and reading shit and paying attention
and really analyzing your thoughts and being objective and correcting mistakes,
Eh,
probably not cause you got dick thrown at you like javelins all day long.
You're just dodging deck.
I mean a girl like that,
it's,
it's easy to rest on your laurels,
but it doesn't mean that,
that to judge them on that.
I mean,
if you've met enough people in your life,
you realize that there's some really hot chicks that are smart as fuck.
Yeah.
It's confusing.
Definitely.
But they're out there,
but it happens.
It,
it's,
it's like they say,
and I found this to be true to the most amazing women are the ones who got hot
after high school.
Hmm.
Yeah.
They,
they,
yeah,
because they had to,
they had a personality and they were smart or this or that.
And then they hit their 20s and they kind of figured out how all the parts come
together and became like,
Holy Shit hot.
They still have that.
They develop that personality or whatever.
Whereas if you're born hot and you just look great all your life,
and I've met,
I've met women like this that they have no clue.
Like they really think life is that easy for everyone.
Right?
Like they,
it's like you understand like everyone,
like some people have to wait in line for shit club is some people like,
yeah,
Eh,
it's no knock against him.
It's like,
you know,
certain people when the birth lottery,
you just want like Michael Jordan ability to fly.
Yeah.
But Michael Jordan is a perfect example.
I mean,
Michael Jordan didn't even make his high school team,
Michael Jordan,
he failed like a lot and then become obsessed,
became obsessed with success.
And then,
but then he also happened to grow to six,
seven with the jumping ability.
You know what I mean?
It's like that was that,
that helped.
But yeah,
it's,
it's great when you do all of that,
but you still have to have,
I think you have to have some talent.
It's like being,
it's like comics,
you know?
I've always thought Dave Chappelle had an unfair advantage because Dave looked
funny when he came out and I don't,
Joey Diaz,
I don't mean that as a knock.
I mean like when you see him on stage before he opened his mouth,
you're like,
oh,
this guy's,
this guy looks funny.
This is going to be fun.
You know Joey's like that.
When Joey starts talking,
you're like,
this guy's hilarious because you think Joey,
Joey's one of those guys.
You he'd like a rocky look ports.
Another one where you think they're playing a character and then you find out,
no,
this is really him.
He's really that guy.
So it makes it even funnier if Joey's a human cartoon.
I mean he just walks out and as soon as he walks on stage,
people start laughing.
They start smiling.
Yeah.
What the fuck is this guy been doing for the past 15 years?
I love Joey Man.
He's my favorite of all time.
I think he's the funniest guy that's ever lived.
I really do.
I don't,
I don't think there's anybody any funnier because I think if you look at common
and you look at stand up comedy,
I really think that we're right now we're in the golden age.
I don't think there's ever been more funny comics.
I think too because of the great comics because the Internet guys like Joey that
probably would have never made it on television and they wouldn't have gotten a
shot on the tonight show back in the day.
Now you get to find out how funny they really are from podcasts and you get to
go see them do stand up and I think if you look at like all the greats,
like if you go back in time,
comedy gets better over the years,
like the greatest of all time.
Like only Richard Pryor is,
he's the one guy that like,
I'll go back and I'll listen to his old stuff and it's still really funny.
It's still really funny but like you go back and listen to Lenny Bruce,
boom.
It's hard to listen to them and it's not really funny anymore.
I think Carlin was always funny once he,
once he got past that Hippie weatherman thing,
once,
once he put that down,
Carlin became just these,
I mean the observations he made were hilarious.
And,
and Cosby and I,
you know,
obviously everything,
everything with Cosby is now tainted.
Yeah.
Cause,
but he's still omic.
Yeah.
Was,
it was a,
he was a beast.
Like you listen to it,
Noah's Ark and some of that old shit and it's like genius.
That was great.
Like it would still be,
you know,
we had this argument once somebody threw it out,
they said,
if caused me started today,
would he have made it?
And I was like,
fuck yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
He knew the adjusted,
they,
they all would have adjusted to the new level of comedy.
The level of comedy is hire people expect more.
It's just,
I think it's higher now.
You know,
I just think that as time goes on,
things get better.
Um,
but at all the guys that I've ever seen,
and I saw Kennison live,
I s I worked with prior at the end a bunch of times at the comedy store,
but he wasn't really prior anymore.
He was real sick and he was in a wheelchair at the time and they,
they would literally carry him chewy from the comedy store and,
and um,
um,
uh,
what,
what the fuck is her name?
Um,
Martinez,
what the fuck is her name?
Anyone.
They would carry her,
they would carry him,
they would carry,
her husband would carry,
um,
Richard Pryor through the audience and sit him down and then they would crank
the microphone.
I'm like,
Shh,
real loud.
Cause he,
he could barely talk and he was on medication and he would drink and he would
drink and he would talk.
And it just wasn't that good and it was sad.
So,
but I,
but I did get a chance to see him,
you know,
when I was younger,
I saw him,
you know,
live in the sunset strip.
I saw the movies and then I saw prior,
I saw Carlin live a few times.
No one has ever made me laugh.
Like Joey Diaz when that guy's on,
when he's on and he went,
his face is red and he's fucking screaming and going crazy.
I just,
I don't think there's anybody better.
I think he's the funny,
I think overall he's the funniest guy that's ever lived.
Yeah.
I got to,
I got to work with,
uh,
Carlin and I met Cosby.
Never got to work with him,
but I never got to meet prior.
He was the only one last summer I worked with Rickles railing.
Rickles is,
he's in his late eighties and it's the same thing.
Like he's off stage.
They haven't been a wheelchair.
He can walk,
but it's like they helped them get around and then they bring them out and then
he sits at a piano and the minute the lights hit,
he's fucking Rickles.
Why?
One of the highlights of my life,
I got it on video is backstage.
Rickles was ripping on me.
Oh,
you're fucking cry the next day.
I don't know what he's six [inaudible] nine six [inaudible] 10 he could kill
somebody,
God forbid.
And you can catch them this weekend.
At a San Quintin and he'll probably be inside Friday cause you know Alonzo.
Yeah,
it took a white man's name so he's not in jail and just shit.
It's just
Bam,
Bam.
And all you can do is sit there and fucking laugh.
Yeah.
Jeff Ross told me work with them too,
and he said the same thing.
He said once he went to the lights are on and the microphone's on.
He comes alive.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it,
it was great to watch and it's one of those things like it's,
that's a video I'll have forever.
Like yeah,
that was a nice brick walls ripped on me.
So buddy hockey yelled at me once.
Oh Man,
I got a great fucking Buddy Hackett story.
Yeah.
I uh,
doing a benefit and Robin Williams was presenting Buddy Hackett with this award.
So I'm outside.
It was,
let's see,
it was,
I was on the show,
I want to say shoemaker was on his show.
And Anyway,
so I'm just outside.
This is when I still smoke,
so I'm having a cigarette.
So Buddy Hackett walks up,
right.
I've never met him.
I don't know anybody.
It's right after dawn and I missed it.
The nappy headed hosting.
Right.
So he comes up to me,
he's like,
yeah,
I know.
I know you're going to let it happen.
Right.
Cause you black comics when it comes to being funny,
I mean the colors you colored guys are just so hilarious when you negro start,
Jesse keeps going says keeps going.
Saying the same thing.
Different words for black and I am fucking cracking up because it's like,
I don't even know.
But it was great.
It was great.
Those,
those guys were,
they had a thing,
you know,
it's different time at a different time and they had a camaraderie and a,
and when they were,
when they weren't on TV or on screen or whatever,
they had no filter like they just did.
That's why he was doing that because you know back in the day that's what you,
that's what you did,
what you did.
They fucked around with each other and they,
those guys didn't even have comedy clubs.
Those guys had to start off on variety shows.
Yeah.
Whether it'd be like a dancer or a band and they'd be like the NMC and they'd
have to come out and you know,
shuck and Jive and it would mc strip clubs and jazz clubs.
You ever had to a strip club?
No,
I did once I did a Jack and Jill Strip club in Woonsocket,
Rhode Island,
Jack and Jill means a guy goes out and the girl goes out.
It was atrocious.
There was no one in the audience and there was maybe like a no,
no bullshit.
Like six people in the audience spread out like two here,
one over there,
three over there.
It was so bad that I couldn't even,
I can't even say I bombed because there was no response.
It was,
it didn't feel like a bombing.
It felt like they weren't even acknowledging that I was alive.
It was the strangest thing ever.
And then this guy and this girl who are both equally unattractive,
the guy would dance first.
I don't remember who danced first guy or the girl,
but they were both disgusting and they both had terrible tattoos.
The guy was coverage tattoos up with like I on his arm and the girl had like the
way I described it on her ass,
it looked like someone tried to chew into her ass like that ubid into hand,
got the ink on your teeth and tried to chew a snake into her ass.
That's how bad the tattoo looked.
It was just a,
it was one of those moments where I go,
wow,
I'm never going to forget this place.
I did have a moment.
I worked with the chip and Dales guys.
What's,
I guess this is hosting a straight,
anybody try to blow,
you know,
they didn't know I wasn't their type,
but
it was some little casino,
you know,
one of those sides of the road casino is about an hour and a half north of
Sacramento.
So we're in the middle of farm country and you know what,
it's just like,
okay,
here's a casino for no reason.
Had to be 1500 farmers' wives,
chicks in this crowd waiting for the chip and Dales guys.
Right.
So I go out there,
so I'm out there for about maybe 12 seconds before the first take it off,
you know?
And it just was one of those did just screaming right.
So,
so whatever.
So I didn't,
I didn't even do jokes.
I just yelled back at him and,
and something in and I would like open a button on my shirt,
you know?
But the funny thing was like it was almost like they weren't in on it.
Like they were trying to fuck the chip and Dales guys,
you know these guys are like,
it's like one of like it's a lottery thing to find.
Which one of these,
it's a straight guy.
And the other thing was these guys were kids.
They were like,
you know,
I guess it's a Chippendale's road crew.
It's not like the main guys.
These guys are like 20 2123 and these women are like in their fifties you know,
I was like,
this is going to end badly.
Monsters,
farmer's wife,
monsters screaming cigarette breath
dragons.
When I was a kid,
I had two friends that were a male strippers and one of them was a,
an older guy used to work out that they were pulled,
worked out to the gym.
I worked out and I'm,
one of them was an older guy,
one of them,
the younger guy and the older guy,
it was was real fucking weird.
It's just real weird.
Like he had a pair of underwear that was a,
an elephant trunk and his Dick would go with the trunk is and when he had like
little ears,
you know,
it was very fucking strange.
He would joke around but shit got real one day when we're all,
uh,
we're all hanging around.
He was talking about girls and you know,
go to this bat,
any guy was,
you know,
it was pretty built girls,
they,
you know,
they go to these bachelor party or Bachelorette parties and you dance for these
girls and the girls get about to get married and she winds up suck on my Dick.
It's crazy.
And we're all sitting around laughing.
I go,
you have to dance for guys and you get to hear a pin drop in that fucking,
you know,
and uh,
he looks at me and I look at it,
I'm looking into his soul man.
He goes,
yeah,
but I,
I hate it.
It's the weirdest moment.
I'll never forget that moment looking at his eyes of him saying,
yeah,
but a hate it.
They hate it.
I'm like,
you dance for guys.
What's that like?
And then everybody like,
yeah,
what's that like?
Finally someone asked,
finally someone asked,
but the other dude was as younger guys,
Young Puerto Rican kid that I said work out with.
And uh,
he wound up doing a lot of dance and for dudes,
he went up to answer for dudes and I think he told me,
and let dude suck his dick too.
It's just like,
he goes,
well,
hey,
as long as I'm not doing anything,
man,
it goes,
dude wants to give me $1,000 to suck my Dick.
I'm like,
what?
Yeah,
I was going to say it's probably just,
it's just money,
you know,
but I don't believe it didn't do anything either.
You know,
dollars a suck.
Is that okay?
Well 10,000 if you suck mine,
well,
Hey,
long as you're here.
Yeah.
Not going to take long.
Right.
So when you leave here,
they're going to say you suck Dick.
Whether you suck dick or nuts.
So you might as well make pick,
pick up 10 grand.
You're already in the neighborhood when a guy is sucking your Dick,
you're already in the neighborhood.
Yeah.
You might as well just suck his dick and make the real money.
It's,
you know,
I'm,
I was trying to think,
I'm trying to think what comedy is related.
Like if there's a comedy Gig that's that bad where you're like,
fuck it,
you know,
a in,
but yeah,
we don't have,
there's no comment.
There's no one nighter where you,
where it is a possibility of you sucking a guy's Dick because they know us.
You're a gay dude.
Unless you're a gate and you're trying to hook it up if you're trying.
No,
I'm talking about where it's just,
it just happens.
Yeah.
Nor is there a Gig for chicks where they wind up,
you know,
for chick comics?
Yeah.
I it,
I don't know what it's,
it's different for women on the road though,
right?
Like they don't go out and get,
their whole energy is different.
They get sad there.
Their whole energy is,
oh boy,
Dick.
They know and don't like,
I don't want Dick.
I don't want you showing me a dick.
Don't they usually bring dogs with them?
They bring a little dog.
A lot of them have dogs and little tiny dog.
The weirdest thing I heard after we did last comic,
we were touring this and that and Tammy passcode said she went to a Gig and a
guy had a life size cut out of her that he brought to the Gig and he wanted her
to sign.
How fucking weird would that moment be?
Ooh,
that's rough.
Is Tammy still live in the middle of nowhere?
She was like in Pennsylvania.
Still in,
yeah.
She's in Pennsylvania.
And,
uh,
she's doing good.
She's doing her,
you know,
she's doing great with Standup,
right?
Yeah.
She's doing great with standup.
She though she was part of Jenny Mccarthy's tour and then she's doing her own
gigs.
Yeah,
that's right.
She does her radio show too.
Right.
Then she got a Sirius XM radio show.
Tammy's always cool.
I love,
always been cool.
We,
it's funny too,
we had a good time when we did the show.
Who else did you do it with a wet season when you are,
I was in seasons two and three.
You weren't Bolsa you got,
well,
three was three was the kind of thrown together season where they took comics
from season one and put them against the comics from season two.
So,
but I did it with Heffron,
Gary Gulman,
Todd glass,
Kathleen Madigan,
Tammy Corey Holcomb,
aunt.
Um,
that's a good crew up to aunt.
And it was the reason why I got in a fight with Buddy Hackett.
I know we,
we know that story and I'm trying to remember what's his name?
Um,
Jay London.
Oh,
Jay Jay London.
J London man.
He's a funny dude.
Man.
Jay's funny man,
but he's a boy.
You talking about a guy who was a mess.
Oh,
he's crazy.
We ain't,
London was selling American flags after nine 11.
That's what he's doing for a living.
Yeah.
And uh,
I work with them.
The first Gig I ever did on television in 1992 I want to say two or three.
I did stand up spotlight in New York and it was me,
me and Jay London and a couple of other people and Jay and I were friends,
you know,
from the New York comedy scene and then he just kinda like faded away and then
he came to La and in 2001 he was like basically like almost homeless.
Yeah.
Before he did last comp.
Like he was the only guy who stood in line on last comic and made it to the
finals of the show.
Wow.
So he went through the whole line.
You went through the whole addition wait outside,
but I'll give it my best j London moment.
We were,
uh,
we were in the house and it was a game.
Hef,
Ron had called it 10.
I don't know if you've ever heard of this,
but there's a group of people and you start telling facts about your stuffs self
starting from the most innocuous thing.
That's number 10.
Like I might say,
you know,
my name's Alonzo,
I'm from New York City,
you know,
and you go around then number nine,
you,
you know,
I had my first girlfriend at 18 or whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
you go number six j j London.
Sometimes I get mad at myself and I ripped pubic hairs out with pliers and I was
like,
that's your fucking six.
Cause I had to go after him.
I was like,
that's number six.
What the fuck do I have?
Like that's six.
And he was serious.
Absolutely,
absolutely like mad at himself.
Like what is your,
what does number,
I don't think we got to number two.
What is that amount of himself for?
Who knows,
who knows?
Jay,
Jay's a sweetheart.
But uh,
but definitely a tortured soul.
There were a lot of demons.
It was,
it was fascinating watching him become famous because knowing him as long as I
knew him.
And then for us for a small window of like a year or so after last comic
standing,
he was really well known low.
Absolutely.
People loved him.
Yeah.
We were at the store.
People would love him.
He would,
people come up to him at the store and they'll go get,
can I get a picture with you?
And He'd be like,
me,
you want a picture with me?
Like he was like,
like genuinely confused.
He never figured it out.
He was a guy who needed someone to take care of him.
He needed a manager.
Yeah.
He needed a man in here that would,
uh,
handle and take care of him,
which he didn't book them.
Just get them booked.
I mean,
it's just like having him manage his career on his own.
Did he ever have a manager?
He,
he was with Barry briefly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
he didn't.
We,
we,
we toured with him for a while,
meet him and Gary Goldman toward for about six months really.
And um,
me and Goldman would call it London itis where you just get tired of Jay.
Like you love him.
But man,
I can't do it anymore,
you know?
But he knew he needed somebody to help him.
It was fucked up because it was,
it's one of those cases where if somebody worked with him,
he could have sustained it.
You know,
he's a guy who could just come in and do 10 minute guest spots forever and
people would love him.
Well,
he opened up for Louie recently in La at the comedy store when Louie was warming
up for his,
a standup special that he filmed there.
And he was really funny,
man.
He's got some great one liners.
He's got some killer one had crabs.
I bought a fishnet stockings.
I'll be over here,
like move the microphone.
He went in on a joke,
didn't go well.
He's the only guy I know who could honestly do the same joke twice in,
in one set because he forgot.
And the crowd would laugh because everyone knew,
like he honestly forgot.
He's already told that joke,
but they were all nonsequitors.
It was like one after the other that didn't,
that didn't make sense.
Um,
the Buddy Hackett story,
if you didn't hear it was Buddy Hackett and,
uh,
and Monique and I
were hosting,
we were the,
uh,
the judges first season of last comic standing,
an aunt aunt's killing,
right.
Doing Great.
And uh,
but he does like a George Carlin joke does a joke from a movie,
does all the shits.
I compliment them.
I say,
you're,
you got great energy.
Your delivery's awesome.
You know,
he really got a lot of,
there's a lot of charisma,
but I've seen those jokes.
Like those are jokes.
Like you did a joke from a movie,
the movie boiler room,
which I guess they stole from Jim David,
who's a comic in New York.
The joke was a,
you know,
they should take you guys to put them on an island.
They did,
it's called Manhattan.
Okay.
You know,
like when you say that and you live in La,
like,
come on bitch,
that ain't your joke right now.
Like this is,
that doesn't even make any sense out of it yet.
But,
um,
when I said that,
you know,
I said,
look,
a comic is supposed to be,
when you're onstage,
it's supposed to be your point of view.
Like that's what everybody wants to go say.
They want to see,
here's the world through your eyes.
Buddy Hackett just started screaming at me.
I ain't never high those jokes,
but far you'll fucking asshole just screaming at me because all those old
Vaudeville dudes would all stay all steel,
all of them.
They all would steal each other's shit and they would go from town to town and
you know,
they would do jokes to Jews walking into a bar and then they would have like a
little thing that they would piece together because no one did television back
then.
They never did television.
Nobody knew.
Nobody knew anything.
He just had a bunch of gags.
It was like your toolbox that you'd bring with you need to go and do it.
And uh,
this is the only,
I mean,
we all knew that everyone knew that as comics.
And you talked to,
Oh guys,
they were alive back then.
They would always talk about that.
Like the Milton Berle thing was the classic one,
right?
Milton Berle stalled everybody shit.
But um,
he just,
I just struck a chord and he was screaming at me,
you fucking half owl to screaming.
He had gloves on.
And I remember trying to figure out what I was going to do.
Like,
am I going to yell back at Buddy Hall?
He's like,
fucking our buddy,
a hacker brother.
He's like 80 something years old.
He means it looks like he's on death's door and he's a legend.
You know,
he's a comedy legend and you know,
and he's screaming at me and I,
and I know why screaming at me and am I going to say you're just pissed off
because your entire career stole.
That's what you guys did.
You guys all still,
you weren't,
you're with standup was back then is not stand up now.
This is,
this is all in my mind and I'm not,
I can't say that.
I just can't say it.
It's not,
it's not my place.
I'll be crucified.
So I decided to just eat it.
I'm not going to say a word.
So I just sit there while he's screaming at me and I'm looking at them and I
don't say a word,
and I think to myself like,
God,
did I do the right?
They're like,
Shit.
And then fucking Barry came over.
W who I've never liked.
He doesn't like me,
I don't like him.
And he was the producer of the show and it was that weird controversy where all
the people that got on the show,
even though we didn't vote for him,
they wound up getting in because Barry was managing them.
It was a disaster because he was producing the show and managing people that
were on the show.
It was fucking gross.
That was when drew Carey and Brett Butler walked off the show in the second
season.
Reason.
I'll talk to you about that.
We'll do that next.
Yeah.
So I decide,
I go,
I'm not gonna say anything.
I'm gonna say it and bury him.
Come,
came over to me.
You know,
you're such a professional,
you just,
you,
I'm,
I'm really amazed that you just did that.
And then way you did and that was beautiful.
You just,
you just handled it perfect.
Cool.
Thanks.
Great.
No,
like I'm so,
I'm thinking to myself,
yeah,
Jesus,
I definitely did the wrong thing.
If Barry comes over and tells me that,
so I,
you know,
I just,
and then Monique was like,
you made those jokes.
You all sugar.
Those are your jokes now.
You made them yours.
I'm like,
you made them yours.
It's a fucking George Carlin joke.
God dammit.
He's doing the choke about George Carlin talking about how fighters fight for a
person.
They wear a belt.
That's a Goddamn George Carlin bit and he's doing this and he's going to do it
on television.
I'm like,
do you know what?
You're,
what's happening here?
I don't say a word.
I just let it all happen.
And um,
two weeks later,
Buddy Hackett's dead two weeks.
So his health was so fragile that him screaming at me at that moment,
if I screamed back at him,
he could've died on that show.
I mean,
that's how fragile his health was.
he was dead.
I want to say two weeks.
I might be wrong,
but it was no more than two months and he was dead.
And so I was thinking like if I yelled at him there,
fuck you,
you'll cut.
That would be a worst.
Boom.
His heart thing explodes.
Yeah.
Joe Rogan kills Buddy Hackett.
Literally killed him.
And this was all,
um,
I want to say this is all pre them and see,
I think too,
it was,
it was right when was the last comic standing?
What year?
Oh five oh four oh five.
So this was pre cause of them and see anything was like 2007.
Yeah.
Well what happened with Brett and a drew Carey and I always felt that they set
them up,
you know,
kind of set them up for this to happen.
So we're doing it the semifinals in Vegas,
right?
There's 20 of us there and 10 of us are going to go forward into the house and
do the show.
So it came down to,
I think it was a,
I think it was Dan that are Herman and somebody else.
It was between the two of them.
And Nat Herman had had a killer set.
And I love anatomy.
Anatomy is really funny,
but I think they didn't see everything that led up to that.
In other words,
we had done our auditions in our various cities.
We had done New York and they had us do some shit backstage.
Like we had a gambling night,
we had a party and Dan doesn't really interact like it's,
you know,
a lot of comics.
You stay to yourself like it's a thing.
And I think all of that made a difference in them picking.
But they had Brett and drew under the impression that they were going to pick
the 10 that went cause like one of the other comics they picked wasn't going to
get on cause they did the same set at both auditions and they kill you for that.
They would like,
look,
if you don't have two different three minutes sets,
you know,
you're not ready for the show or whatever.
You know.
So I felt they set uh,
Brett up.
Cause I remember when Britain got pissed and got up out the chair and walked off
because I think we all knew that they weren't making the final decision.
You know what I mean?
They were like celebrity judges but they weren't going to,
you know what I mean?
It wasn't,
you weren't really judging,
they didn't take you into consideration at all producer's decision,
which is why it was so frustrating for people when they found out the barrier
was managing people.
Yeah.
That one,
that one thing I can say when all that went down,
I had no connection with anybody cause cause Barry managed some.
And then I'm Ross,
uh,
Bob and uh,
Ross from the tonight show,
they had had a management company before they were scouts for the tonight show.
And I think one or two of the comics had been with their management company
back.
But I was like,
nope,
check my history.
I got nobody,
no one pulling for me here.
But then I went back a few years later,
season five and I was one of the judges.
And so now I'm on the other side of the table and I got to say,
I don't know how it was when you did it.
They didn't interfere with that.
Like they didn't tell us who they want it,
you know what I mean?
Like they didn't really,
the only thing they would tell us if somebody did that act before,
you know,
in other words,
like they tried out with it in oh five and now they're back in Oh six with the
same act.
Cause they were like,
no.
And then there were a couple of times I'll never forget,
there was this one,
uh,
this chick had been like Miss New Jersey or something like that.
Like she was a beauty queen and she was hot as hell.
Not Funny at all,
but just fucking amazing to look at.
Right.
So they were like,
are going to go in the house?
I got to pass it.
Yeah.
They were like,
you got a passer,
you got to bring her back to the ninth audition.
And we're like,
like,
no,
no.
Like it's not going to,
we brought her in when we were at Gotham's in New York.
Man,
it was the most awkward silence like her act.
It was like this monologue and just the crowd was just like,
it's where it's not even bombing with it.
Yeah.
The look on your face right now.
I don't know if there's a camera on you,
but if people,
if you saw the face Joe,
just me.
That was the whole,
yeah,
a lot of that
painful feeling.
Beautiful little hidden short
hair.
Look at her hair,
you know,
it was one of those,
one of those,
I have no idea.
What if she got good,
like really good?
Could have maybe.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I think she would have,
she had been plucked into the actress pool if she was funny at all and even
remotely decent.
Yeah.
They didn't tell us anything who they want and who they didn't,
but it was real obvious when we all like,
we would talk about it like before buddy got mad at me,
you know,
I like,
did you guys pick them?
How did,
how did this guy get through?
Like it was,
it was,
uh,
there was a conversation when we were trying to figure out how someone got
through that.
We didn't pick that none of us pick,
Monique didn't pick him.
That was what it was.
I don't think I was talking to a buddy.
I think Monique didn't pick him and I didn't pick them.
I go,
you didn't pick them down and pick them.
Right?
It goes,
well how this guy get through that doesn't make any sense.
And then there was,
um,
there was,
uh,
the Brett Butler thing and then we had read that the,
the judges would really just sort of for show and that really is the producer's
decision who to get on and knocking on the shelf.
Ultimately.
Ultimately it was because part of it,
um,
like I was talking with Jay,
Katie Anderson about it,
cause KP was working on a show.
He was writing for Jay,
right?
And Kp say,
he said,
you know,
well part of it is you gotta have a balance in comics,
right?
So you can't have like all white guys are all black guys or is it like they had
an idea of how many slots,
cause he told me to think when the season I went on with Corey Holcomb.
He said,
look,
they only thought there'd be one black comic.
They were like,
but you and Cory were both so funny and so completely different that they were
just like,
yeah,
bring them both on.
And then when it came down to,
there were six of us and fought going to be five finalists.
Right.
And me and Cory were both still in the running and we were like,
all right,
one of us ain't gonna make it.
Like it ain't gonna be two brothers in the final five on NBC.
That just ain't going to happen.
So whichever one of us makes it,
we,
you know,
we were back the other one,
cause we knew,
we knew that doesn't make any sense.
If you guys were the two best,
it should be a possibility.
Yes.
Should be.
But it's,
it's,
but it's not just that show.
You know what I mean?
Like,
that's how TV works.
Like you,
you know,
I've always said that like when people talk about discrimination and TV,
there's definitely discrimination in TV,
but a lot of it,
but one of the colors they see as green,
you know what I mean?
And some of the shit they do,
like when they do stereotypes,
like we were talking about it earlier,
you know,
like Friday night I was one doctor Ken show as a bouncer.
Alright.
I fucking nail bouncer.
All right.
I've been a bouncer on most sitcoms in more movies have,
you know,
could I,
could I get mad and say,
well,
you know,
I can play a professor.
Yeah I could,
but I damn sure I could play bouncer.
You know?
And it's like that's how TV works,
right?
Like every hot blonde is dumb on TV and every Sitcom Dad is a bumbling idiot,
you know?
And it's like that's,
that's how they,
that's how they play the game.
So you can get mad at it to an extent.
And I understood like,
like the Emmy speech that Viola Davis made,
like I get that.
Like she's like,
if we had more opportunities,
there would be more black actresses like me and that,
and I never want to insult people who act on that level by lumping myself in
that category.
Like I'm not an actor like the,
I am a,
I love playing the bouncer.
It's easy and I get health insurance,
you know,
but as a common,
so you're a professional comics and legit professional comic and the idea that
you,
you wouldn't have you and Corey Holcomb,
who's also a legit professional comic.
Hilarious.
You too.
Hilarious guys.
That it's not possible that you can get it to the finals.
That's fuck it was possible.
But we kind of knew he knew of the possible who you like this,
this the on UPN.
We got
the WB on a WB shit.
It would've been,
they would've been,
listen,
Mister Hef,
Ron,
we got to see you later.
Corey got business to take care of.
Well,
at least half.
Ron's funny.
Heffrons hilarious.
And after all the dust settled,
like we were all cool with it.
You know what I mean?
Like it was,
it was what it was and it was a great shot for all of us.
But I,
I liked it better than than I do now.
I think the show was better when you had all the reality and all that cause I
think now it's just straight stand up really.
They just,
yeah,
it's like they just get up and do stand up against each other and America votes.
I don't even know.
America don't even know if America votes or I don't even know how they do it now
because we,
you know,
when we did it,
they didn't have Twitter and shit like that.
So crazy.
I didn't lie.
I did it when we had my space and I had a girlfriend who would get mad at me
because of things chicks would post on my space after they saw me on TV.
I got no control over this.
She would get mad at you for things.
Other people posted it.
She gets,
she never,
she was never able to adjust to TV.
But you know,
the,
cause you know how TV is like pretty women are like a decoration on TV,
you know what I mean?
They're always around.
And whenever there's an event,
there's hot chicks there that nobody really knows how they got there.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I don't know who invited them or what.
They're just here but that,
but that's how it is.
It's,
it's always like that.
And she was never comfortable with that.
And I was like,
look,
if they're going to fuck anybody,
they're going to fuck a producer.
Like they know,
they know how this game works.
They know they only going to get so far fucking the winner of last comic
standing that that's not a career.
You might be a step though.
I might be a stepping stone.
So at best to get you across the creek,
I might be able to get you backstage where you could meet somebody,
you know?
But,
um,
yeah,
she was,
she never,
and she was hot,
you know,
but she never couldn't handle it,
couldn't,
couldn't get used to it.
There's,
um,
there's some of those things,
some of those events where they bring in girls and I knew girls that would get
hired,
they would literally get hired.
They'd get paid like 1000 bucks to go to these events and parties and mingle
cause they want to just be,
that's what I'm saying,
it's just filled with hot chicks but they're not like,
I used to always say they're not real.
They're just here like not meaning they're not real.
They're real people.
I'm sure they have a life and stuff but in this atmosphere they're here to make
this room look good.
They're here too.
They're also here.
They also here to find some sort of a producer that might be able to take care
of them.
There's a lot of that plus comp coyotes,
bless him if you,
you know,
they would find this to make it work.
Some chubby Jewish dude and just start working them a close it my friend and one
of my favorite comics met cause then I got my own problems.
Me and Matt be on the road and he'd say that a hundred times whenever you read
something in the paper,
like some guy,
you know,
Tornado,
bluish trailer away in his dog died,
man.
I was like,
yeah,
I got,
you can concentrate on other people's problems way too long and you get lost.
You lose yourself.
It's cheese to eat that.
That's the other thing about social media.
It's too easy to get caught up in nonsense that really shouldn't affect you at
all.
Yeah.
And some people do more than like,
like it's unreasonable.
Like,
okay,
we can't save everyone from everything.
Like in a perfect world we could,
but no,
the world's not perfect.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
and it's the same way with Hollywood and show business like you,
you have to remember this shit ain't real.
You know,
it is on some level,
but a lot of it is just glamorous and they treat you good and they love you.
And they,
I,
I think,
I think what helped me was the fact that I worked in the real world before I got
into this because I remember my first job,
I was a truck driver for the show power rangers for the kid show and I'd never
worked in TV and I didn't know anything about it.
And we go and there's breakfast and then there's lunch and I'm like,
what the fuck?
And,
and you know,
I'm hearing,
I'm hearing someone complained and I wanted to say,
you know,
in the real world,
you've got to get your own food.
They feed you every day.
You might want to show a little gratitude when you're on the power rangers.
You wish you were on friends.
It's just how it is.
Everybody always wants better.
No one's ever happy.
There's always a bigger,
better deal around the corner.
I had fun with that,
showed that that show was actually,
that's where I learned everything about TV.
Like I learned to whatever,
you know,
I learned what the best boy is and what the key grip.
Like you see all those titles and you're like,
what the hell is that?
And that's where I learned who all those people are.
I learned what upstage Matt while I was on a television show told me,
could you move upstage?
I go,
which way is that?
Which way's upstage?
It's off.
And you know they were,
they were a bunch of people.
Oh Geez,
fuck did he get here?
And Comics Mad.
They were mad to,
I worked with some actress.
It really didn't like the fact that I had never really done any acting before.
And then it was easy.
It's not that hard,
but upstage the way it used to be.
And those Victorians,
Shakespearian stages,
it was a,
a ramp,
like the stage was not flat.
It was like it was elevated in the back.
And the idea being that you could see it through the entire complex as they move
to the back of the stage upstage.
You could see in the back right there,
otherwise the ramp so everyone could see it.
Then they just,
they were flat figured out,
Hey,
wait a minute.
If we put the seats in a ramp,
we can make the stage floods.
One of those great moments in theater that nobody got credit for,
that the guy who said,
hey man,
how about if we put the seats up hill and we can keep the stage each flat.
So I'm going to tell you my great Joe Rogan story cause I don't know if you
remember this story.
I will always remember this story.
This,
this was,
no,
this was a great that this is my second year at Montreal.
I had gone once and I had done new faces and then um,
you know,
just doing whatever.
It was great for me and that's when I became a comic fulltime,
Blah Blah Blah.
And you know,
so I come back the next year and I bumped into you and I think you were either
your still on news radio or you had just finished news radio or something like
that.
What year was it?
This 99 98 yeah,
probably.
He's probably on it still.
I think it ended at nine nine and then Kevin James showed up and I think Kevin's
show was about to hit or it just hit or something like that.
And you grabbed me and you're like,
come on,
we're doing spots.
And I rode around in a cab.
What you and Kevin James crashing stages and now I'm just coming off new faces.
So I'm like,
what the fuck?
I'm hanging out with Joe Rogan and Kevin James.
I'm a fucking comic now.
I'll always remember that man that was so fucking cool at that time.
Cause you knew me from the laugh factory but it wasn't,
but you know what it,
you know what I mean?
Like you guys were both on sitcoms and you'll recognize everywhere you walk in
and I'm just this,
that their security.
Nice fun
comic.
I remember that.
I remember being,
I remember driving around with you,
but to me,
I mean I never wanted to be on TV,
you know?
So being on TV was just something like,
Whoa,
okay,
I'll do that.
That's a lot of money.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm on TV.
But any moment while I was on t stand up when I was on TV rather I was thinking
this is going to end and I'm gonna go right back to being a stand up.
I always thought of myself as a standup.
Yeah.
I love being a standup.
You know it's,
I mean I would love that everyone would love that hit TV thing.
Yeah.
That's the lottery payoff,
right?
When you get one of those and you,
you know,
make a ton of money.
But there's nothing like being on stage and,
and the,
and the other thing I've always loved is the respect of the good comics.
That's everything that's ever when,
when the,
when the good ones,
when the pros,
the masters,
whatever you want to call it,
when Hitler and,
and you,
you know,
you got it.
Cause they just treat you like you're one of them.
You know that that was always the thing.
When they talk to you,
they treat you like you're like,
okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
dude,
I was in the parking lot of the comedy store in like 94 or something like that.
And Damon Wayans,
he had seen me on stage and he looked at me,
he goes,
you a funny motherfucker.
Funny motherfucker.
God Damn,
that was funny.
And I remember like my whole was tingling.
It was like,
Ooh,
Damon Wayans had that.
Like to me that was like just the most,
like the most elevating thing that could've ever happened.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm legit now.
Can you leave this?
And then you become that guy crazy.
You know,
like in the past five years,
I've definitely become the old guy,
black guy.
There's so many young comics.
I mean,
oh man,
I was watching you and oh man,
just talking to you.
I'm learning.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I got you.
Cause I remember like George Wallace was my guy.
Like I used to see George at the laugh factory and I talked to him and this or
that.
And he's still fucks with me about it.
Like we were in Vegas,
we were having lunch or something.
He's like,
yeah,
there's a lot.
So just sitting around waiting for me to die.
I was like,
Damn Right George.
I take over this whole Las Vegas operation.
He hated that operation man toward the end I talked more about it at the comedy
Magic Club.
He came back backstage and I was there and we were hanging out and talking and
he said it.
He goes,
it is not easy.
He said it was hard.
You know why they for Wallet?
Because he had a pay for everything to promote it because he was going up again.
He said the reason he stopped doing it because other clubs,
they were giving it away free,
so he's four wall and then trying to sell tickets when they're giving away free
tickets to so and so show because they're backed by the casino and he said
that's why he said you just got to where you couldn't.
You can't compete with free also.
Then you got to go on the road and you haven't really established yourself on
the road and decades because all this time he's been in Vegas doing this one
place,
just trying to pack this one place with people out of town.
So he's got the billboards,
he's got the,
the,
the things on top of the cabs and all that shit and he's,
he's got a good hustle.
I'd keeping it together in Vegas,
but that shit doesn't mean anything when you go to Philly.
No,
the people that haven't gone to Vegas,
they're like George who?
George Wallace.
Oh yeah,
I remember that guy.
They're not going to come.
They're,
we're not going to cut.
They don't know what's better there.
Was he on comedy central last year?
You know,
w when was the last time you had a special,
that's always been my weakest thing.
I never been great at marketing.
It's hard.
Marketing.
Marketing's a tough Gig,
but he,
he had a great run in Vegas,
so for a long time he had a great run there.
I think nine.
Yeah,
I think nine years.
But I talked to another guy who had one of those shows and he told me,
he said,
man,
you said you'd see them taxis.
I get a bill for that.
Like every month,
like the casino gives me a bill.
The Casino?
Yeah.
Cause the casino puts up the money to put your picture on top of a hundred taxi
cabs,
you know,
and then at the end of the month you get a bill for that or they take it out of
what you've made in the box office.
Wow.
Yeah.
So it,
yeah,
it's a tough,
it's a,
unless you're,
unless you're a big name,
you know,
unless you're one of those big Vegas shows going in,
but you have to be like Hosni spears or something like that.
Like I never hear about a comic having a big name.
Like I guess carrot top he does well,
he's more of a variety show.
I mean he's a comic for sure,
but he's more of a variety show because he's got the props and he's been in
Vegas long enough.
Like he's built,
he's built a show there.
You know what I mean?
Like people know him.
It's Kinda like Siegfried and Roy type thing.
Like carrot top is a Vegas show.
Yeah.
He,
how long has he been in there?
I have no idea.
Probably like 10 years.
He's been there longer than George.
So does no one else though.
I mean,
what's her name?
Rita Rudner was there.
Rita Rudner.
Louie Anderson.
Oh yeah,
Louie.
I had a show there.
I didn't remember his.
And um,
who else didn't Eddie Griffin do something there for why I think Eddie Griffin
still has a thing like,
yeah,
but it's not,
it's not all week.
It's like weeknights.
That's a weird thing.
It's like a Monday or Tuesday,
Monday and Tuesday night or something like that.
Yeah.
I've always wondered what that would be like.
Like there was one time we were negotiating to do a,
uh,
they wanted to do a reality stars thing in Vegas so they'd have like,
like I was going to host it because I won last comic standing and then they were
going to have like the winner of the country singing.
Like they couldn't get the big,
you know,
the American idol winners and stuff like that,
but it was all the second tier reality shows like the winter to country music
singing show and the winter of this that there's some show on country music
tells me like American idol,
but for country singers and Ma,
I probably get to 20 million people to watch it and they wanted all of us to do
a show and I had hoped it went because I wanted to see what it would be like to
just be on a Vegas show for like to live in Vegas and work in Vegas for six
months.
You had a,
you could go crazy things,
so I think you'd go crazy and I think your world would get very weird.
I think your world gets weird if you live there.
I think there's something strange about being in the city that is a,
I love Vegas,
I love working there.
I love doing the UFC there,
but I love getting the fuck out of there.
Just as much as I love getting in there a week is pretty much as much Vegas as
you can.
Never even do a week.
I do two days,
that's all I've ever done and even two days when Sunday rolls around,
I take the fucking 6:00 AM and I'm not kidding.
I've,
I've stayed up all night and I say,
well,
I'm just going to have a fucking red ball and play with my kids on Sunday
morning.
I'm,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna stay awake.
Fuck this.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm not taking something new and flight or 1:00 PM flight in.
The last thing you want to do is try to drive.
Yeah.
He tried out on the weekend.
If you're going to drive that a Vegas,
you better leave at Saturday night at 5:00 AM you got to do it because otherwise
it's going to take forever.
I know people,
let's take eight,
nine hours when I go,
when I do a club,
Jamie,
oh hang out.
I don't hang out on the strip.
Like I like,
I'll go to a gym somewhere off the strip and I'll go eat somewhere off the strip
and then you're there at night and that's okay.
But,
but the idea,
and I'm not a Gambler,
like the idea of just being in that casino,
doing that for a week,
but I,
but I've talked to people who work there and they're like,
you,
if you work here,
you don't even hear the bells.
Like they walk to the state,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
But they go on stage,
go on stage,
do your show,
leave,
go home.
You live somewhere else away from the Strip and recommends,
well,
I know people that live in Henderson,
like my buddy Max lives in Henderson,
like see no nice suburb.
He loves it.
And now he,
he,
he's a professional pool player,
a lot of pool action in Vegas and there's a lot of people that live outside of
it that,
that really like it,
you know?
But like,
uh,
I dunno if you know,
do you know Matt King?
Matt King now Mac does it.
He's a magician.
He has like an afternoon show.
I think it Harris,
but he's been there like he just sold his 2 million at the ticket.
Like he's been there forever.
It's his gig and he loves it and he,
you know,
it's like a one hour show at like four in the afternoon for the whole family.
It's like,
okay.
And he loves it.
Yeah.
And he's been there
15 years.
Well,
if you had to choose to Chine living in Vegas and living in Toledo,
I'll take the fucking Vegas every God Damn Day of the week.
No offense to Lido,
but you know what the fuck I'm saying.
I think there's something weird though about living in a city that is the place
that people go to get crazy.
Yeah,
well you have to get away.
That's why you can't,
I don't know anyone who lives there who goes to the strip on a regular basis.
Yeah.
Anyone I know who lives in Vegas,
they're like,
yeah,
I'll go.
Occasionally there's a show they'll go to or they'll take their friends,
their when their friends visit,
but otherwise they just don't go to the strip.
Have you ever been to that bar on the top of Vegas?
The top of a,
the men as it Mandalay Bay,
I think it's Mandalay bay.
The bar at the top or it looks out over like it's like the most or something
like that.
Yeah,
it's insane.
And you,
you,
you get up there and you look out at all that neon and all that craziness.
And it literally is like an image of the future from a science fiction movie.
Like if you were in the 1920s or something like that.
And,
and people like imagine,
what do you think it's going to be like in 2015 well,
this is what they would probably imagine.
See,
the thing I love about Vegas,
and I've always said if somebody came from another country,
they're like,
I want to see America.
I got five days,
we're going to bed.
Because you know,
you get,
you get like the buffet at Circus Circus,
right?
And you see,
you see the Americans Hillbilly and his,
you know,
natural habit,
right?
And then you go to like the Bellagio and you see that,
you know,
the beautiful millionaires.
And you just,
that's the thing I love about Vegas.
Like it is the craziest,
if you watch the strip,
you will see the craziest collision of cultures,
you know?
That's true.
Is that a pimp talking to a Kansas City grandma?
Yeah,
this is Vegas.
Yeah.
And that's a genuine pimp right there in a,
in a green suit.
Yeah.
He's right there walking the strip.
You know,
you just,
that's what I love about Vegas.
It is,
it is the best and of America.
It's
like fine dining.
You know what I mean?
Like just the,
you know,
steak house with the greatest cut a meat you've ever had or you know,
three 99 all you can eat shrimp.
Oh yeah,
that's shrimp dies.
Yeah.
There's the circus.
Circus is a classic one.
The Rivy areas to be classic,
but tearing
all the,
it's all now it's all the corporate mall casinos where you can't tell which one
you're in.
Well,
they're just trying to rake up money,
especially they were hit hard during the downtime and the economy when,
uh,
2008 when the economy crashed.
I was in Vegas and I was asking one of the guys who was a cab driver.
I said,
what do you think?
Like what's the down?
Like how much is it down here?
And he goes,
it's about 50% yeah.
They laid off a ton of people.
Like the hotels were empty and all loads.
Yeah.
Cab drivers and all that other stuff.
A lot of them lost all the service people,
all the people that were dependent upon folks hopping around town and also
giving out tips.
You know when people in the money's tight,
those tips are the first thing that dry up.
Like you're on your own bitch.
You know that that whole industry of people relying on people coming there.
That's a very tricky in the housing being dropped,
all they built all those condos and all of that shame.
No shame.
Atosh he's a comic's comic store.
She accidentally married two different gay guys.
She's fucking hilarious.
She married two different dudes and it turns out they were gay
and gay guys,
but she bought a house out there for like a hundred grand.
Yeah,
and she said it's amazing.
She does a great house in a nice neighborhood.
She goes,
I got a yard,
I got to know a few people who did that.
Yeah,
you've got a friend,
real house there,
a buddy don Barnhart.
He did that.
He moved there,
bought a nice house,
you know,
him and his wife and he's been there for years.
And if you live in La,
the idea of a nice a hundred thousand dollar house,
it's like a fucking Unicorn.
Like what are you talking about?
$100,000.
That's it.
That's all you have to pay payment on a house.
But you know,
lucky in,
in America,
you see that?
You know what I mean?
Like I was in Indianapolis and um,
I don't know if you have,
did Bob and Tom?
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
to houses out there and I was like,
so how many should,
each guy was like,
eh,
it's about three 54 huddle.
What,
like my townhouse cost mod,
I could live like a king.
Yeah.
You get to be an Alison.
I got Annapolis,
but I gotta live in Indianapolis.
That is the problem with all due respect to Indianapolis.
It's not happening,
but I'll do respect Alonzo stay in the know.
But you gotta think like,
like we were talking about with Tammy Passkey telly as a touring comic,
you really,
you know,
your home becomes just a base and you travel out of it if you have somewhere
with,
I remember Schimmel telling me,
cause Schimmel moved to Scottsdale and he said,
man,
I got a beautiful house.
He said,
I got a airport.
that's all you need.
He said,
if you're a road comic,
if you got a good airport,
you can live anywhere you want.
It is all you need.
But when you leave la or New York,
you give up the weekday spots and you give up the auditions and it isn't like
there,
there is an aspect of the business you give up when you leave.
New York and La do weekday spots are big.
The weekday spots and also being around great comics,
you know,
um,
Tom Rhodes just moved to La and Tom had been,
uh,
Tom has been like living like a,
like a vagabond.
Like,
he just lives out of a suitcase,
but living in hotel to hotel for years,
I think for like five years,
he hasn't had a,
an actual address.
And He came to the comedy store and it was like a Friday night or something like
that.
And he saw,
you know,
borough was on,
I was on,
it was just packed fucking room.
Uh,
it just madness.
Just one,
one smash after another.
Like all these people were there that were really high level.
It was just a great night of,
of,
of comedy.
Uh,
Neil Brennan killed,
I think Chappelle mine is stopped in that night.
It was just madness.
And then he said,
I got to fucking,
I got to move here.
And he was like,
I can't,
he goes,
I'm not seeing good comedy.
Yeah.
It's too easy to,
uh,
it's too easy to rest when you're on the road and then you come here.
Even last week,
like Tuesday night when we did dumb show and it was like me,
Joey,
and you with Dom Irrera,
you know?
Yeah.
That's,
I don't get that in India.
You're not going to get,
it's you,
you,
it elevates your own level.
Because,
you know,
you realize like,
I got to ramp my game up,
you know,
and like what we were saying before that you're,
that joke he did about wiggers like jet,
Joey's,
Joey and I were like howling on the phone laughing about that one joke.
We're,
we're cracking it like that.
That's important for comics to ha.
Yeah.
You have to get into,
into town and in New York now is,
it's going crazy like that,
but it,
it pushes you because he like,
man,
like these guys are good.
Like I got to stay sharp and now you have the next generation coming up and
they're doing like,
like I like working some of those alternative rooms and some of those youngster
rooms just to be around something different.
Like not the bullshit side,
but the ones who are real comics,
but they're coming up and they're there.
They're just funny,
but they're doing it in a different way.
Yeah.
I like being around that.
Well,
there's a group that are coming up now that grew up with the Internet.
Yeah.
This is the first,
the first generation of standup Comedians,
these guys that are in their early twenties,
you got to think 1994,
20 fucking one years ago.
That's when the Internet came around.
Yeah.
They all grew up with the inner when they were five and six years old.
Technology is normal to them.
Totally normal and a part of life.
So we started talking about looking at encyclopedias.
You break out the scrolls of the elders.
They should go to the,
the sacred cabin in the,
where they kept the scrolls.
And then the other side,
when you see older comics who don't change their act,
ah,
said they'll make like a videotape reference and you're like,
videotape.
That's the worst,
you know,
and you've got to set the clock on your set the clock.
What you heard someone getting a joke like that recently in the past three years
I've heard,
haven't heard set the clock on the VCR.
There's nothing sadder than a lot of these,
uh,
these guys that just don't write anymore.
There's something about like,
musicians can pull that off.
Like musicians from the 1960s can do the same songs.
If you went to see,
you know,
fill in the blank,
you know whatever band and they were doing some shit from the 1960s you be like,
oh shit,
that's a great song.
But if you went to see a comic and they were doing jokes in the 1960s she'd be
like,
what kind of sadness am I looking at?
Like I said,
I do these jazz cruises and I love it because I get to work with some of the
greatest jazz musicians in the world and they're brilliant.
But I,
I bring that up and they love when I fuck with him about it cause I'm like,
look,
I got to do a show Monday and then I do another show Friday and I got to do two
different shows.
You are playing some shit.
Miles Davis wrote in 1947 and they think you're a fucking genius.
You were playing some shit to dizzy Gillespie played after the war.
That would be world war two and they think you're brilliant so and that,
but I fuck with them.
They love it though because it is true when you're a musician and if you have a
hit song,
you have to play that song,
you know,
no matter how old it is or whatever it is,
like yeah,
you have to do that song.
And like if I do a joke like uh,
we heard that one and I could never be like,
all right,
it's sort of Eddie Murphy and delirious 1983 I like to do gunny Gugu
there's no cover comics.
They used to be,
do you remember Ilan Gold?
Yeah.
He used to do impressions of Comedians and doing it with their own material,
but then people started getting mad at him cause his impressions were dead on.
He did amazing impressions,
but he would do it with their material.
But that's,
but that's funny cause you're doing it right.
You're not doing it as if you came up with it yourself.
Right,
right.
You know,
but he still had to stop doing it.
Yeah.
He got in trouble a little bit.
People got mad at him.
I don't know who got mad at them,
but that's what I had heard.
So then he started doing impressions of these comics with material that he
wrote.
I heard some guy did an hour of Patrice and put it on youtube as if it was his
own.
Well,
he had done a bunch of other stuff about that Patrice had done in the past and
not acknowledged it.
And he tried to pretend that it was a,
obviously just an homage to Patrice,
but it wasn't the plagiarist.
That's,
that's insane.
People are insane.
Yeah.
People think they can get away with shit.
There's a lot of nutty people out there that think that they're going to sneak
by.
And you know,
some of them do because the audience doesn't,
you know,
we know,
but the audience doesn't.
So yeah.
So you fully audience,
there's some guys to this day that it's knocked by.
You tell people that guy he got famous by being a plagiarist.
You're like,
what?
And then you go,
yeah,
go Google it.
And you'll tell them like they'll go Google it and like what?
Yeah,
but they don't care.
You know?
They do.
Yeah.
You know,
you can always tell them,
no,
I don't.
I wonder if the artists cares,
like if a comic or the whoever,
you know what I mean?
Cause you said you know it when you're,
you know when you can bullshit the crowd and you can make,
you could make millions of dollars but then you're in the room or you're on the
show with the real comics and you know,
just same thing with singers,
you know what I mean?
If you're,
if you're one of these singers where the machine is doing it,
but now you're in a situation like,
Oh shit,
like award show these.
Yeah,
these are like,
like you call yourself a diva but Aretha Franklins in the room and you're like,
oh shit,
this,
this isn't it
going to go it because like you were what you were saying like that the respect
of the old guard,
like the respect of respected comedians like come,
coming up to like,
you know,
we've all had that.
Like I tell them that the Damon Waynes while I'll never,
I'll never forget that because it's in the parking lot.
I was like,
whoa.
He probably doesn't even remember right now.
But just being,
becoming friends with Robert Schimmel and I'm like,
I'm really friends with Robert Showman.
Like he's real,
he's a real comic and I'm friends with them.
Like I guess I'm a comic now.
Like I'm a,
I can be a comedian.
Like it doesn't seem like now we both,
we've been around so long it's just normal,
but damn the beginning is so fucking shaky.
Yeah.
I think they'll always be some moments with some comics where you're like,
wow,
yeah,
that's for sure cool that I notice I'm friends with this guy or whatever.
So those guys don't have that.
Those guys know that we know that they're full of shit.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that eats away at them.
I then always ate it,
ate away at him and see Ya.
That was on him and see his biggest thing so that no comics liked him.
His biggest things,
you can never got anybody's respect and you see chew away at him.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a tough,
it's a tough place.
And then the other thing that's funny is when they take an actor and they call
him a comic.
Yeah.
Michael Richards.
You know,
that's what I've heard,
Richard.
It was like you're not a calm,
like,
you know what happened with Michael Richards?
The same shit that got you arrested.
Michael Richards came to the comedy store before he went to the laugh factory
coked out of his mind and he was just a real aggressive and talking crazy shit
and just wasn't just a Zahn of it is just out of it.
But I've watched him go up at the comedy store and uh,
my initial thought was like,
Oh shit,
I didn't even know Michael Richards does stand up.
And he would go onstage and the audience went nuts.
But then three minutes in they were like,
when does this guy started telling jokes
what he do?
I'd watch him and it'd done.
Then he would just
do a Seinfeld move,
like the head shake law,
something like that from Seinfeld.
And the crowd would love it for a little bit.
Nothing.
Yeah.
Well you got it.
You know,
that's the thing.
But that's the beauty of standup,
no matter who you are.
Right.
Even Seinfeld said that like,
no matter who you are,
you gotta be funny.
Like he was like being Jerry Seinfeld got me the first five minutes and then
they're like,
all right,
what else you got?
Yeah,
I mean it's fucking shows an hour long and dude,
you better come with some funding.
What do you this Cosby thing,
man,
we're,
we're talking about that,
about how this guy for the longest time was thought of as like one of the all
time greats and now people look at him and they think,
well,
here's a guy that's just,
he's just a piece of shit like that,
that flip flop between being like this respected,
adored,
idolized all time.
Great Comedians.
Like if you had to pick a Mt.
Rushmore standup comedy and there's only four guys on there,
one of those fucking guys until the last year.
One of those guys is going to be bill Cosby it,
you know,
I'm so torn because I love Cosby.
I think Cosby's one of the greatest,
if not the greatest of all time definitely would be on the Mount Rushmore.
So now it's like,
okay,
still a great comic,
but bad guy,
you know,
at at best flawed human being.
But I don't understand.
I'll never understand the motive it head to beat and it's just my opinion.
There had to be some weird fetish involved because it's not like you can't get
laid if you're a bill Cosby.
I think he quoted there had to be some kind of weird turn on or something.
You know,
like I'd be,
I'd be interested in what a psychologist would say.
Like why does someone do this?
I think a lot of people used to do it.
That's what I think can think so.
I think in the 1960s dosing people wasn't I,
you know how we were talking about drunk driving in the early days,
drunk drivers,
no big deal.
I think they used to think the same way about dosing people.
You know,
cause bill Cosby used to have a whole bit about Spanish fly.
Yeah.
About giving girls true.
Slipping a girl.
I'm Mickey and she gets all Horny and fucked up.
I mean that's true.
You're drugging someone against their will.
They don't know it.
I think that was a normal thing,
I think.
And not,
it was never a good thing.
And you know,
ethical,
moral,
right.
Reasonable people never did it.
But I think it was way more common than we would like to believe.
Yeah.
I may be people dosed people.
I think it was like,
you remember that scene in animal house with the girl's passed out,
the dude's got the devil on one shoulder and the angel,
yeah,
you lay leave her alone.
Fuck her.
Fuck her brains out.
Tucker tests.
Like you couldn't even do that today.
You couldn't have that in the movie cause that's rape.
But back then it was like there was at least the possibility that this guy was
considering having sex with this passed out woman.
And then today the drug thing,
like
the Cosby thing,
drugging someone is thought of as a heinous crime.
Like you drug people and you raped him.
It's a heinous crime.
Well and,
and it was then,
but yeah,
you maybe society looked on it differently or maybe it was something amongst the
boys.
Yeah.
That you did.
I don't,
I don't really know.
Playboy mansion and it,
it's,
you know,
it's horrible for everyone involved.
You know what I mean?
It's horrible for the women involved.
It's horrible for what's happened to his lifelong reputation is all gone now.
You know it.
And it's almost,
it was like with Michael Jackson,
like there's a generation that only thought of him as a freak and it's like,
you guys really don't understand who he was musically to the seventies and
eighties.
Cause in the 90s,
he just became a freak show.
You know,
when I was a kid,
there was a radio station in,
um,
in La or in a Boston rather.
It was a called the rock of Boston w I think it was called [inaudible].
I think that's what it was.
And they played Michael Jackson when Michael Jackson came out and that,
I remember the DJ saying,
look,
I know what you're saying that this is dance music,
but listen,
this is just a great song.
And the guy who played,
um,
I think it was a,
trying to remember what song it was.
It might've been beat it.
I don't know what it was,
but it was like that,
like d thriller,
when thriller came out,
everybody just stepped back and just said,
what the fuck.
This is just genius on a level that no one had been able to reach before.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I did this award thing and they were given an award to Quincy Jones,
you know,
and he produced thriller and I was joking with him about,
I said,
you know,
Quincy Jones,
dear brothers didn't know who Eddie van Halen was.
Van Halen doing or a Michael Jackson record them.
Like only Quincy would think,
yeah,
let's get the baddest rock guitarist and have him do a solo with Michael
Jackson.
Like who he played guitar,
you know,
but,
but that was yeah.
And people,
but people don't know like,
and,
and the videos,
cause that was when video just started and he had dance shit.
Like when he did that thing in smooth criminal where he leaned forward,
you're like,
that's not humanly possible,
you know.
No,
he,
uh,
he was like,
no one before him.
There was no one that you could compare him to.
Right.
Like you could say,
you look at Elvis and you go,
yeah,
Elvis was really good singer and a good performer,
but Elvis kind of borrowed a little bit from the old rhythm and blues guys.
And they borrowed a little bit from the way Chuck Berry's to dance.
And there was a little bit of this and a little bit of that when Michael Jackson
came along,
you gotta go,
okay.
Yeah.
Compare that to any,
and the other thing about Michael Jackson,
and I always said that this is the part people don't talk about,
like he was world famous at 10.
[inaudible] like when you talk about he's fucked up.
What can you imagine everyone in the
world knowing who you were when you're like 10 years old?
Like,
you know,
by the time you're 15 adult women pass out,
like,
can you imagine walking into a room and having people pass out just because you
walked in a room,
they're overcome and they literally think like,
how does that affect you,
you know,
as a person?
Well,
we,
I think we all have that weird effect.
Um,
when we meet someone who we can't believe we're really meeting them and we're
just like taken aback like,
Whoa,
we've all been starstruck before.
We've all had that weird effect.
Even if it's on a low level,
like,
you know,
you're at a comedy club and curse rock shows up,
right?
Like,
like Whoa Shit Chris.
Right?
I mean you can be a professional comic and Louis C K Kza like,
oh shit,
Louie c guys here.
When that guy would walk into a room,
it was that times a million,
right?
There was nothing like it and no way to prepare for it.
And he never had a normal life.
Like you were talking about your career as an airplane mechanic and like you,
you knew regular people,
you had regular jobs,
he had been to jail,
you know,
the,
all the whole deal.
You ran the whole gamut as an,
as a grown adult human being.
This kid camera when he was in the Jackson five and his fucking brothers,
his brothers who were all grown ass men had a sit back and watch that little
brother just run shit because their dad gave birth to this one.
Just super genius.
Like they had all these kids and everybody was really talented.
Latoya and Janet and Jermaine.
Everybody was talented.
But then there was this little motherfucker,
the last one out of the box that just had magic,
right?
He hadn't magic.
And then you're getting back the Cosby,
what you're talking about.
The other thing is like how many hundred million dollars did he give to United
Negro College Fund?
Like are kids like bill Cosby paid for my college education?
You know what I mean?
So it's just such a weird thing.
And it's awesome.
Often like human beings that are flawed,
they're not flawed in every way,
right?
They're not all bad.
And there's a lot of people that do terrible things,
but they were actually really good with other things.
It's,
you know?
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
My friend Eddie has an interesting theory about bill Cosby.
He said,
you know what,
at the end of the day,
Bill Cosby at,
even though he was super famous and he probably got turned down,
he probably got turned down occasionally.
It probably drove him crazy and didn't like it.
And so when like one of these,
one of the stories that I was listening,
I was reading rather,
uh,
whether the girl was talking about her experiences that Bill Cosby,
that it started out and it's like mentor friendship sort of relationship that
eventually he drugged her and then fucked her while she was passed out,
like can and that she,
you know,
she just felt violated and horrible.
But it was this mentor thing that he would angle in first and then when he
couldn't get the pussy that way and was like,
oh,
okay,
have a Cappucino.
Right.
Do you want a Cappuccino?
Here you go,
boom.
And the next thing you know,
she's passed out.
Like he got tired of working for it and decided to just go back to his bag of
tricks.
Might've been,
I,
I again,
I have no,
I have no idea cause I,
I can't imagine it's also,
you know,
because it's something I can't imagine doing.
So I don't know what the motivation would be.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's,
it's so evil.
Yeah.
And when,
you know,
this woman was on television talking about it and,
uh,
I think she was a lawyer and she was saying,
you know,
they were talking about the legal ramifications and apparently one of these
women,
her accusation is inside of the statute of limitations.
Yeah.
But they're not going to bring him to trial.
You don't think something that,
what do you think was going to happen?
Uh,
he's going to,
it's going to cost them a lot of money.
He's gonna pay,
uh,
you know,
whether they,
whether it be some,
like,
I think it's Gloria.
All red has the class action lawsuits.
So whether it's like,
okay,
we give her a ton of money and she divides it up amongst the women,
or she goes,
I'm fucking crazy trip and buys a Rolls Royce fingers or herself for the Gold
Dildo.
Or they come up with something else like you.
You know what I thought was was like weird and it was funny,
but in a horrible way with Jared.
Oh yeah.
With Jared paid like a 1.4 million so that 14 victims get 100,000 each.
And it was like,
okay,
so 14 kids who he solicited,
he offered money for sex to solution is to pay them each $100,000 out of the
settlement as shit.
Just,
you know,
it's a horrible thing to laugh at,
but it's like,
isn't it something wrong with that,
but that's how it's going to go down.
Well,
it's another parallel that Jared and bill Cosby or like in that bill Cosby is
undoubtedly a piece of shit.
All right.
At this point in time,
anybody that thinks he's not guilty,
you gotta be crazy.
Right.
So he's a piece of shit,
but he's also one of the greatest comics of all time.
Yeah.
You can't take that away from him and Jared from subway,
he still lost a hundred pounds and I what to say?
He's hard.
Yeah.
It's hard to lose a hundred pounds.
He might've fucked a few kids,
but that guy lost a hundred pounds and uh,
he did it eat and shitty sandwiches.
Yeah.
So it's even more impressive.
I mean,
when you eat,
if you're eating subway sandwiches and still losing a hundred pounds,
you're fucking put in some work bed.
It's running uphill.
Jared gets to say,
well,
I've got one thing in common Cosby,
like if not really not,
no,
nothing in common.
What a fucking freak.
What a fucking freaky creep.
And again,
nobody knew it when his best friend was like a pedophile.
How did his best friend come out as a pedophile?
Is that recent?
Is that a recent discovery?
That's how they,
that's how they,
I found him was through his best friend.
I don't know when they knew it about his best friend,
but his best friend like ran his charity organization and I don't know if his
friend was a registered sex offender or when it came up,
but that's how they,
that's what led to Jared first,
the friend.
And then rarely.
Yeah,
I did not know that.
Yeah.
Now that you're saying that.
I remember briefly by the time I was,
it was on my radar.
He was already arrested.
Yeah.
And he was already going to jail.
No,
I first heard about it when his friend got arrested and they would like this guy
runs Jareds charity organization and I don't know if he had anything to do with
kids.
Like if it was like,
you know,
little league or whatever,
but there was something wrong with this guy.
Being involved in a charity and helping children does no worse cause they're
both awful.
But somehow it is worse.
Somehow fucking kids is worse than drug and people and having sex with them.
Yeah.
It,
I mean when you do it,
it's all worse.
It's all sick.
But I think the thing about kids is like kids aren't sexual.
Yeah.
You know,
women are women like it.
If you have a sexual attraction to women,
that is normal.
I mean drugging them and raping them isn't,
but they are women.
But with kids,
there's nothing sexual about a kid.
Well,
how old were,
they didn't have sex with some 15 year olds.
Asexual.
They might've been,
but I think some,
I don't know.
Well they,
they only,
part of his plea was only one count.
So he don't like,
in other words,
they're only charging them what one,
even though there were others involved.
So do you know what's even so you know something,
you know what's funny about that?
Like he's talking about a 15 year old and like we were talking about this the
other night,
you know,
like when,
when uh,
the 50 year old guy has the 16 year old,
like a 15,
six year old girl could be hot,
but she still 15 or 16.
If you're an adult man,
if you're,
if you're over 20,
21 late,
you still like 18 and a girl 16 that makes sense.
If you're 48,
yeah,
she's a kid.
That's a baby.
She's a kid that she may have developed.
She may have the body,
she may,
you know,
walk around half naked.
Don't be alone with her,
but you can't get out of the room.
It's still a kid.
It just doesn't,
you know,
the problem on the same day,
five instincts are horrible.
Instincts are horrible.
If you got a girl,
like that girl I was talking about in Houston that Ian and I met Ted at this
tiny waist,
this big juicy ass,
like she was a grown woman.
But if she was,
she's probably built like that when she was 14 I had a buddy he used,
he,
he's a principal now,
but he taught high school when he was like 2124 so he's the guy that 16 and 17
year old girls,
they want him because he's,
and it was like,
man,
I don't know how you do it.
I don't know how you do it because these girls are coming at you hard and their,
their bodies are perfect and they're wearing nothing.
You know what I mean?
Cause there's 16 right.
So there were it.
And it's like,
and,
and they're just starting to be aware of it.
Yeah.
And they,
and he's a man,
like,
he's not the 17 year old boy.
Like he's a man,
but he's not an old man.
Like he's not old,
creepy guy.
And the only a few months away from legally.
Oh Man,
I,
he,
he was a better man than me.
I was like,
I couldn't,
let me tell you something.
When in my early twenties I have to work at a high school.
When I was in high school,
there was this kid that was a not kid guy would be a kid.
Now if I was talking about him because he was in his twenties,
he's a Spanish teacher and uh,
he fucked one of my friends.
She was 15 she was,
uh,
at the time I think,
I actually think she was 17 but still,
you know,
he was fucking her.
She was in high school and he was a Spanish teacher and he was fucking hard.
It happens.
And this is pre internet.
She couldn't ran them out.
Yeah,
but it's not pre dad got a gun.
Yeah.
It's not pre dad got a gun cause that's some shit that they will not convict
you.
Well,
ages of consent are very strange man.
It's,
it gets,
and there's also,
it's a weird gray areas that come along with ages of consent.
Like,
here's one of the issues that's happening right now with kids and technology is
that young people are taking photographs of themselves naked and passing it out
to their friends and then getting busted for child pornography.
Like there was a girl that she's 15 years old and she would send dude's pictures
of her pussy and uh,
you know,
just what it sent it to them in text messages.
The cops arrested her and charged her with trafficking child pornography to
other children.
Yeah.
That's,
it's one of those that if they want to bring you down,
they can use that charge.
But they couldn't,
they was,
she wound up getting cleared of it because the judge was like,
wait,
what the fuck are you doing?
Right?
Like what do you,
why,
how coming out there arresting robbers.
Like why you trying to stop a young girl from showing a picture of her pussy?
Yeah.
It's um,
it's one of those things,
like I said,
they can charge them with it.
They don't always,
but there's a time,
like if they want to bring you down,
they can.
I think it's one of those things they used as a threat against you,
but again,
it's just,
you know,
I do not want any 15 year old pussy pictures on my phone.
I don't,
you know how you hear me joke about it like they're young.
No,
I don't.
Too much trouble.
Yeah.
Too much drama,
energy,
whatever.
Nope.
No,
thanks.
I got a friend who's a dentist and he's in his 50s and,
uh,
he's divorced and,
he's talking about dating.
We're,
we're talking about it and I go,
uh,
I go,
do you like what,
how old did the other girls that you dated?
He goes,
well,
here's the thing.
And it goes,
I don't mind a mature lady.
And he goes,
I don't mind them.
A lady my age,
she goes,
I'm a,
I'm not a young guy anymore.
And it was,
I'm 58 years old.
He goes,
I just looking for some Nice company and go to dinner.
And he goes,
but he goes,
there's two different things going on.
He goes,
you've got the younger ones that are like in their thirties they just want to
fuck he lives.
They want to fuck.
And then they want to get out of there and he goes,
then you get the older ones,
they want,
they want to settle down,
but they want everything to be their way.
Yeah.
Cause they're all like,
they're in their forties.
He's a grown.
What?
They're not malleable,
you know.
And that was interesting.
He was talking about how he goes,
these women are set in their ways.
Well I'm that guy,
you know,
I'm the,
I'm the old bachelor and a yeah,
you've,
how will do you know I'm 53?
Damn.
You look good.
Black don't crack black.
Don't crack.
It's just badly one day.
But you look great for 53 though,
man.
Seriously post for 35 easy.
The girls in their twenties,
it's just too young.
Like,
like on occasion,
if I get some 20 year old pussy is a gift from the gods.
Yeah.
God was like,
all right,
I'm going to give you this.
Don't get attached to it,
you know,
just enjoy the day.
But no kids,
no,
no kids.
Wow.
How'd you do that?
So,
uh,
started comedy late,
started comedy at 30.
So in my thirties,
when most people have kids and so religious,
I was an open miker well,
I did not want the obligation of a family.
You know,
it's hard,
man.
I have a friend who is married and he has children and he's just starting out
doing comedy and he doesn't know what to do and he,
he can't,
he can't struggle the way we struggled.
Right.
He can't go and just do a set for 75 bucks,
five hour drive away,
all that shit.
You can't do all that.
So that was,
so that was that.
But uh,
but you know,
dating,
like I started seeing this woman and she's in her late forties and it's
fantastic because she's got a son,
but he's,
you know,
almost like he's in his late teens,
so that's not a big hassle.
And she's a woman.
She's comfortable with who she is and everything's cool and stuff.
But um,
yeah.
And then you get some,
the worst ones for me early to mid thirties when the date is an interview.
It's like,
so it's like you do find the right girl.
How long do you think it would be before you got married?
Yeah.
Um,
so why don't you have kids?
Are you open to it?
Do you think about it?
Not,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
Uh,
I tell him like,
look,
it just didn't,
I didn't have the right one at the right time.
I said,
now I'm open to it.
It could happen,
but I'm not really looking at being an old dead,
you know,
I joke about it like if I have a kid now when he's 16,
if I say you can't have the car,
and he says,
yes,
I can.
There ain't shit I'm going to be able to do like son of a bitch took my car,
me 69.
It's took my car,
look at this,
the loan at 69.
He's fucking yolk still.
Yeah.
So I'll just do it.
And Dana,
Jim Smoking crack and fucking hit those weights.
Some guys do it and some guys have the APP.
I could have it,
you know,
like they say you could have as a man,
you could always have a kid but do you want to and uh,
I think now it would be more likely like if I met a woman who had a young kid
and I took him on as a stepchild or something like that would be more likely to
happen.
How crazy is that?
Your 53 and Joey's 52.
Yeah,
that's living,
living.
That's fucking hard.
Miles man.
You know something we'll all be gone and Joel,
you'll still be here and probably like,
like that's how it is.
You know?
That's how it happens isn't a true with comics.
The comics either die too young or live forever.
You have a lot of them,
right?
You don't,
you don't hear about a comic dying.
It's 68 years old.
That's true.
Yeah.
It's laughter's the best medicine.
Like that idea is a,
I think there is something real about the fact that you're making people laugh
all the time.
You're having a good time,
a lot of laughter and fun.
I mean we have more laughs on a regular basis.
Then a great percentage of the people.
Yeah.
Because our friends are the funniest people at world.
I give you and I like you and I,
the other night,
Tuesday night hanging out at the laugh factory,
we were just how and laugh and just how,
and then you leave there.
Your whole body's like,
ah,
you're energized and you do that all the time and there's nothing terrible.
I mean our whole work day was like,
we both did 20 minutes said,
well this is it.
Like people ask me,
what are you doing?
Well I'm doing Joe's podcasts.
Like that's my just my job today.
But the,
I think the other thing is we don't stop doing it.
Yeah.
You know,
cause like my business manager,
she's like,
well,
you know,
we got this retirement thing set up and this,
and I said,
really?
When have you ever heard of a comic retiring?
She's like,
what are you?
I said,
we die.
It's what we do.
We do this and then we die.
We might work last what you find,
you'll find a different niche.
Like,
it may end up doing the old folks home circuit in Florida,
you know,
but I'm still going to be doing my 20 minute spots at seven o'clock.
I look at Carlin,
I'm doing 20 after Jello,
didn't come and die in a hotel room somewhere on the road,
you know,
died in his hotel room.
Well,
even,
um,
what's his name?
George Burns.
Like he died at a hundred,
but like he did his last set at his hundredth birthday or something like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and,
and I remember,
I remember when,
um,
when Rodney was coming to the left factory,
you know,
and in his last days,
Rodney was coming to the laugh factory in a bathrobe.
Yup.
I remember that.
He would just come down the hill from his house in his robe.
Well,
he go home.
Stay front of arenas in a bathrobe.
Yeah.
I was working when I was 19 years old at Great Woods in Mount Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
It's like this,
a performing arts center.
And I was backstage,
I was one of the security guards and Rodney was backstage and I watched him walk
around with a bathrobe on,
well that's how Rickles was.
But that's because of that.
Back in the day you didn't put your pants on because you would mess up the
crease.
So we were doing,
yes.
So when we,
um,
there was a Seinfeld episode about that,
but it really is true.
When Rickles was backstage in Montreal was in a rope,
I'm going to start performing in a robe.
No,
he fuck it.
Fuck it out of.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if you're a robe guy.
Slippers,
a robe.
No,
no one's aware.
I,
it's slippery.
Where do you buy?
I think you can only get slippers for the month before Christmas.
That's the only time slippers are for sale.
I guess he get them online.
I don't see a store that sells slippers.
He doing,
I'm going online.
I'm looking for slippers.
You know,
Rodney was party until the fucking very end too.
That was one of the things that people said about Rodney.
He was doing blow and drinking and having a great time.
Smoking joints,
smoked joints for every show to the bitter end.
Why not?
You know,
cause it,
cause if you're Rodney,
you can what?
Somebody can tell you.
Aa.
Rodney,
slow down.
We don't want your high before this show.
Well Rodney is one of those crazy stories too because he took a long time off
and was like aluminum siding,
sales.
Race is family or something.
And then went back to comedy forties yeah,
I think it was like 46 when he went back to comedy and then hit and then did you
know all those movies and all that crazy shit?
Yeah.
They ran with Rickles in his robe back stage.
That's a classic picture.
Oh my God.
That is classic.
Yeah.
Look at him with a knee high socks.
Rope Dude.
Send that to me.
I want to put that on Instagram.
Yeah,
I will.
That's awesome.
That's hilarious.
That was a,
you know,
different generation,
different generation.
And someone's going to be saying that about us.
I'm the,
yeah,
those guys just working t shirts.
What were they thinking?
Those guys used to,
there was no internet when they started.
They had to promote themselves by going to local radio shows.
He would be like,
hey,
they had radio back then.
But that works sometimes,
you know,
if it was a good market,
if it's a yeah.
Or if it's,
if it's the morning guy who's been there for 30 years,
if it's a good show today,
you still have those?
There's a guy in Rochester weeds.
Oh yeah.
The week he's still around.
Still kicking it.
Yeah.
And,
and it's like in the morning and Rochester,
everyone listens to brother weeds.
Like you literally go on there and sell out your show.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's a few of those guys.
John Dare and Kansas City.
Yeah.
There's a few of those guys are still out there.
They used to be,
uh,
used to be a good one in Phoenix.
I wonder if they're still on this.
This has been a few that like still,
but it's fucking hard.
The syndicated guys have taken over the whole country.
Yeah.
Guys like a Bob and Tom that has like a hundred different markets or,
um,
Steve,
uh,
Steve Harvey does he do that?
But yeah,
he's got a big radio show.
Tom Joiner,
Steve Harvey's one of those dudes.
Like he's got so many jobs.
He does so many things that he puts out a new book like every year.
Does he write those books?
I think he probably wrote the first one.
I don't know how much he writes.
I don't know how much more but,
but they,
but it's not,
and,
and the funny thing is it's not like any genius advice,
you know what I mean?
Like,
well,
if you want to keep a good man,
don't be a whole no,
like,
like where your dress a little long,
it puts,
put away your whole shoes,
you know,
stuff like that.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I never thought of that.
Oh,
so I shouldn't be a Ho.
He's an odd character that Steve Harvey.
Yeah,
I met him once for a loop.
We joked around a little while he was hosting the Apollo and I did it.
And,
um,
they was cool,
but I don't know him,
you know,
I don't have any,
any relationship with him.
I had somebody the other day texted me,
can I,
can I get them tickets to Kevin Hart?
Shit,
I couldn't get me tickets.
I did.
I did bt with Kevin Hart once,
an old one.
I don't think Kevin's gonna stop shitting and say,
Oh fuck Alonzo's at the door.
Well,
they think that we know everybody,
that,
you know,
everybody in this,
there's so many people in that business.
But even when you know,
people at certain times when it's a little,
I think it's a little awkward to hit him up.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
like Chapelle was doing a bunch of shows in Montreal and I know him,
I don't know him well,
but I know him,
but I just bought tickets.
I'm not going to,
you know what I mean?
Try to get to him and then like,
then it gets fucking awkward,
you know,
cause you know,
a thousand people are hitting them up while you're up there.
So it's like,
you know,
just,
I'd rather just go and have a good time.
Yeah.
Those are the awkward calls or texts you get from people that you barely know
and they want something you,
yeah.
Yeah.
And do you don't feel weird asking me for this.
Right.
It doesn't end.
It doesn't,
it doesn't bother them a bit.
Now.
Some people are brutal too.
They just keep hitting it.
And it's really funny when you ask me for someone else.
Yeah.
Like,
Hey,
I heard you on Joe Rogan's podcast.
I want to go to UFC.
Really?
I'm sure they sell tickets.
Joey Diaz gets that.
He gets out all the time.
He'll,
he gets,
I bet.
Cause you guys are tight.
He gets angry at people.
You know,
people want to get on this podcast and they tried to go through Joey.
He gets,
he can't go through Joey and then fucking angry.
The thing is the people you would give it to are the ones who will never ask.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You know the ones you'd be happy to do it for.
They're the ones who would never ask you for,
uh,
for anything.
There's a lot of people that have that distorted misconception that this,
this business is all about finding the right connections and then those
connections,
like you have to work those connections.
And that's how you get to the business.
That's what you get for those.
Some people do that.
Yeah,
but they're not good.
You're right.
It is good.
One,
not talent,
it's just,
it's salesmanship backstage.
It's being everyone's friend.
One thing that does happen for sure is that you find someone who's really funny
and then you go,
well,
who's that dude hanging out with?
And then you out.
Oh,
he's got friends.
Like Garrett guarantee you their friends are funny.
If they're funny,
like if you know Ari should fear and you go,
Ari's funny shit.
Who,
who's always friend,
you know,
like Ari has some friends from New York that I don't even know.
And then,
uh,
I,
you know,
he tells me about them and I'm like,
oh,
I want to meet that dude.
You know,
like I go,
I want to have that guy.
Cause they wouldn't be hanging out with him if they weren't.
If he tells you they're funny.
They're funny.
There's definitely that.
There's that sort of connection that definitely helps.
But you gotta be talented.
Cause if you're not,
we all have those few friends that were friends with back from 15 whatever years
ago and then not really that good,
but you're still kind of friends with them and they're like,
hey man,
you know,
why don't you take me on the road with you?
Hey man,
how come you never work on your fucking act?
Yeah.
Hey man,
how can we not really comedian,
you know,
to people I admired the people who weren't funny who got funny because I mean I
think I was pretty funny from the start,
but I,
I know some people who just weren't,
and I had my,
cause you kept doing it hammering when nobody believed in you when nobody
thought you were.
And maybe you weren't funny.
Maybe you were just bombing,
but you knew there was something there and you kept doing it.
Like I admire that.
I think that's a lot harder than being funny and just going out and being funny.
I think you're right.
I don't want to name any names,
but I know for
guys that are like that,
they just incrementally got better.
Yeah.
And then you know,
just kept chipping away and kept chipping away.
And then once they started to develop in real confidence,
then it started taking off for them.
Then we started getting some momentum.
It's hard to figure out man.
Yeah.
That's why,
you know,
like you were saying like meat and Comedians,
you know like uh,
Kevin James and I had taken you for a tour of a Montreal.
It's like yeah,
I'm in awe man.
Cause it doesn't seem like in the beginning it just doesn't seem like it's going
to work.
Fuck.
It's like it's so it's all of it.
Yeah.
It's so slippery and they're so big.
Like I remember when I started out when I was opening for Tommy Davidson,
like it's been a summer opening for Shami.
And I was like,
man,
when they say his name there's more applause than my best joke.
Just saying his name.
He got a bigger applause,
break them.
But I always felt like it's funny cause sometimes you meet people or you have
somebody open and for you,
I don't know if you get this,
cause you probably bring yours,
but you took like,
how long have you been doing this?
12 years.
I'm like,
what?
And you're hosting like what was your,
do you have any ambition?
Like even back then,
like my thing was like,
yeah,
I want his job.
You know what I mean?
Like any headline or I opened for,
I wanted to beat them.
I never even thought like,
um,
I guess I want to open for you for the next nine years.
No,
fuck,
I want your job.
But there's a lot of guys that are like local guys,
like in Nashville or whatever,
that just host when comics are in town and yeah,
you got to get out of those cities.
Yeah.
And,
and some do it for fun,
which I get,
but if you have real ambition in the business,
you gotta you gotta be,
you know,
like I tell,
I tell,
it's like,
you know what,
your job is be funnier than the middle.
You need to blow that middle off stage.
That's what you have to do.
Cause it cause you,
if you want his job,
you got to show you can do it.
You true sit here and if you got to announce a drinks,
you better come up with a funny way to announce drinks.
You know that's,
that's part of your job.
Yeah.
That's why it's,
it's tricky working with people on the road to,
do you find the,
do you ever work with guys that try to steal your shit and step on it?
They like twist it around a little bit to fuck with your premises.
I've heard guys,
not so much that,
a little bit of that,
but I've heard them doing something from somebody I know who had been there.
You know what I mean?
So they're doing up in Lincoln.
That sounds familiar.
And then you're like,
wait a minute,
he was here last month.
But you know when they do that they're not going to get out of that.
They're not going to get out of that circle.
You know what I mean?
Like,
say,
say they're a middle act and the south and they're stealing material from
headliners tour in the country,
you're going to stay a middle act and the south because,
cause once you leave,
people know who did that.
They know who wrote that.
Yeah.
It's a different world now.
Are you doing a podcast at all?
You ever thought?
Yeah,
yeah,
I do a podcast.
It's,
it's,
and it's,
it's very interesting.
I love my podcasts called who's paying attention and I do kind of a weekly news
wrap up thing,
but it's just me talking about shit.
I read in the news and,
and some of it by yourself,
like,
don't burn us the morning podcast.
Some of it is,
some of it is the more insightful stuff that I can't do in the comedy world.
So I'll give my real opinion on it than other stuff is just me joking about some
crazy shit in the news or making fun of some stuff in the news.
But on occasion I have guests,
like I did the La podcast festival and I had guests and people like it.
So I guess I need to,
uh,
I need to take it to the next level.
What is that like?
What does the podcast festival like?
I've,
I've heard of it was just never been,
it was actually pretty cool.
It's just doing a lot of podcasts.
Like you would do your podcasts in a room with a big audience.
That's just it,
that that's what it is.
You're,
they have different ballrooms set up,
you know,
different sizes,
I guess from like 50 seats to maybe a few hundred seats or I don't know what the
biggest ones were,
but um,
yeah,
and you just do your podcast live for an audience there and they do them one
after another.
So the audience that,
I guess they buy a ticket and say they might listen to your podcast and then
walk out of yours and go listen to Todd glass for a while and come listen to me
or whatever.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
excuse me.
Just that a weekend of podcasts all in one place this year.
Yeah,
I did it.
It was fun.
I was surprised it was last month.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I was surprised because they had asked me to do it before and,
and I don't think
a lot about my podcast.
Like I'm always,
I'm always flattered when people listen to and I get to eat.
Like when's the next podcast?
Cause I do it about every week but I don't have a set day to do it and I'm like
you're listening.
Well that was the name of various,
anybody paying very flattered that you were listening to on a regular basis.
But yeah,
I liked doing it.
I like it because I get to just give my opinion on shit.
You know.
How long have you done it?
My book episode one 20 so it's been about two years.
Yeah.
Wow.
The won't those things build man now you're going to get a lot more people
listening to it.
Listen to this.
Yeah,
this,
this is fantastic.
I mean this is great because you're one of the big ones and you've got a huge
following and this and that.
But it's also because you and me and we talk about it,
we don't get to hang that often.
We've known each other a long time.
We cross paths here and there,
but it's just this was,
that's why this was always something I wanted to do and fun.
Just cause I like you.
My phone was the last text that I had with you was a year ago before this.
The recent one?
Yeah.
We ran into each other at the laugh factory and then the last one we were
planning on doing a podcast but we just pulled it off.
Why not?
You know,
and that's,
that's how it is,
you know,
cause we're both traveling,
doing our thing and this and that.
I mean that's the other thing about being friends with comics.
When you reach the headliner level,
you don't see each other anymore.
Yeah.
Unless you work together,
you work together or that's like a festival or a show or something like that.
The store or the laugh,
archery or the Improv.
That's one of the reasons why I take guys on the road with me too.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I never use like a local guy.
I always take people on the road with me cause I want to work with,
first of all,
I want to work with really funny guys.
And then I also don't want to be alone.
I want to work with friends.
I take people when I can,
but a lot of times they are like,
the places don't want to give up a room or they don't.
They're like,
we got a local guy that we pay 50 bucks a show.
So if you're a guy,
come in and do 50 bucks,
you know,
whatever.
I always paid,
I paid for the hotel room,
I paid extra money for the guys.
I always get more money than me.
It's like,
I don't know if you're aware of this,
but even when I didn't,
even when I didn't,
I was like,
ah,
I did it too many times by myself and it was a crap shoot.
Like sometimes you'd work on the road and the guys would be fun.
You'd work with a great middle act and he'd make a new friend.
But that was half the time.
Yeah.
And the other half the time you'd work with idiots and you'd,
you'd hate yourself and then you'd have to plug your ears while they were on
stage because they were so terrible.
You hated the audience by the time he got up there.
I hate the places that have their local favorite,
you know,
and they put him on your show and either he's like some filthy guy or it's just
not funny.
You know what I mean?
Like it,
like he's fooling that one audience at that club every week and he thinks he's
great,
but you're like,
ah,
yeah,
I've experienced that.
It's,
you know,
and you just,
or the other thing I hate is when the green room is the hangout for the local
comics.
Oh,
that's the worst.
And I've always thought like,
that's why you have a road manager.
Yeah.
Cause you have somebody to say,
all right,
everybody out.
You know that the worst is when they start bullshitting with you and like you're
about to go on stage,
you're going over your notes and they want to fuck around and hang out and
they're talking to the waitress and complaining.
And they're drinking.
And you're like,
what?
What is this?
Yeah,
but you don't even work in here.
I remember like this was back when I was opening for Tommy.
We were somewhere and his security guy wouldn't let me in the green room really?
And I was like,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
and I fucked with Tommy about it.
Cause I knew Tommy and I don't think Tommy knew,
but I was like,
yeah,
I'm kind of on the show friend of his like not just a fan with the guy wouldn't
let,
he wouldn't let me in living color areas.
Yeah.
Well he was huge back then.
What is he up to these days?
He sees door and he's doing this thing working live.
Um,
he did a tour with Tony Rock and some more.
Tony Rock is fucking hilarious.
That dude,
it's funny at Tony's funny.
So they were on tour.
They did a tour together.
But yeah,
Tommy still around still in the game taught.
Tony Rock is one of those guys who were like,
he might have actually been held back by the fact that his brothers Chris Rock,
I don't,
you know,
I don't know.
It's funny,
like I see more similarity in them now than when I first met Tony,
but not intentional similarity.
Just in similarity in the sense that they're brothers.
But,
um,
it's weak because he never talked about it,
but you know,
he's Chris's brother,
you know what I mean?
It's so,
it wasn't the same.
It wasn't the same as like the weigh ins where you know,
their family and they worked together and they do projects and stuff like that.
I don't know if Tony's ever been on the same stage as Chris.
Whoa.
That's kind of crazy.
I don't know.
Maybe he had,
maybe as,
I'm not,
I'm not saying he hasn't,
I don't know.
But he never,
he never pushed that.
He's Chris Rock's brother,
but you know,
he's Chris Rock's brother.
Yeah.
But I'm saying that he's so good that like people almost don't take him
seriously because he's the brother of one of the greatest comics of all time.
Yeah.
He doesn't get the props is he deserves,
right.
Cause people think he's,
but he's not riding his brother now in any way.
It's like the opposite of nepotism here.
I'm going to suffers from it.
And so he's not Jim Belushi,
like Charlie Murphy,
like jokes around about bringing and Eddie Murphy's brother,
like people like,
you know,
like he's like,
like people would just yell at them.
Charlie,
my bay,
like they yell at him and he goes,
does that ever get tired?
And he goes,
no.
He goes,
as long as they're not saying there's Eddie Murphy's brother,
like,
because for years I was just Eddie Murphy's brother.
He goes,
I'm happy when people yell out of Charlie Murphy.
They know my fucking name,
you know?
Yeah.
I guess.
I mean,
that's the price you pay when there's Famor talent like that in the family and
just such immense fame and talent.
Yeah.
I mean,
in those two situations,
Eddie Murphy and Chris Rock to the funniest,
most famous guys of all time.
And you,
you know,
and they have brothers do standup too.
Yeah.
That's a grind.
Well that was,
I just watched,
um,
Chris Farley documentary.
Oh.
And his brothers on stage doing stand up.
Whoa.
And it's like,
I mean he's talking about how funny Chris was and stuff,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's Kinda,
it was only one of those in the family,
you know what I mean?
Like that.
That's Kinda probably not going to be another one.
No.
Well he was definitely not doing enough coke.
Yeah,
you gotta you gotta do more coke.
Yes.
You want to be like Chris,
you gotta be,
but apparently up he was like that all his life from when he was a little kid.
I met him at the,
uh,
backstage at the,
a set of news radio.
He was friends with Andy Dick and this is,
you know,
Andy Dick was a hard partier,
hard harp.
He's all sober now,
but he was hard partier.
Chris rock or a Chris Rock.
Chris Farley was there with two very hot looking young girls who look like
they've been up for days.
They were very attractive but just looked fucked up and he was gray.
And when I mean gray,
I mean like wet cardboard,
Gray.
He looked like he could die any second now he was sweaty and gray and pale and
his eyes,
there's like bags under his eyes and he was just on some kind of crazy bender
and he was there with these two girls and I had always heard that he was this
wild partier.
And it wasn't long after that that he died either.
But I remember seeing them,
they're like,
whoa,
they weren't fucking around like this kid is really doing it.
But that's what,
that's what I was talking about.
That's when it's not fun.
No,
you're beyond like,
it's not a party.
And what kills guys like that is you have the unlimited money to do that.
Yeah.
And you basically had permission to do it.
As long as you can make another movie or another show or another record or
whatever.
Like I read Clapton's book,
which was actually really good.
And in the beginning of the book he says,
you know,
with the amount of drugs and alcohol I did in my life,
I should have been dead.
Right.
And then about two thirds of the way through the book is when he sobers up and
you're like,
Holy Shit,
how is he not dead?
Like when you read about how much he did and the quantities and the just at the,
you're like,
this guy's not human.
Like,
yeah,
you should have been dead.
Well,
what was he doing?
Just,
uh,
everything,
and large amounts of pills and cocaine and me,
he talks about,
he did one show for like 23,000 people in a total blackout.
Didn't know he was there and you know,
yeah.
Just tons of pills and alcohol.
And how was the show?
They would
imagine it was pretty good,
you know,
take her out.
Yeah.
That was the life though.
That was what those guys were embracing.
It was,
there wasn't a generation before me.
There was a jazz musicians before them,
you know,
there was,
uh,
some,
the older blues guys that,
that fucked around with drugs and did heroin and stuff like that.
But for the most part,
those hard party and rock stars from the 60s and Seventies.
And it was no one was like,
they took it and there were new drugs,
you know,
acid was new.
Cocaine was,
I guess,
relatively new as Ellen on the consumer level.
Was it really?
Yeah.
I think cocaine had been around,
but they weren't a lot of people who did cocaine before the 70s.
Well,
they would just get it from Coca Cola.
You wanted to get fucked up cola early days.
It was in Coca Cola.
And then you watch that show.
Narcos.
Did you see?
I know.
I keep hearing about it,
man.
I keep hearing.
It's amazing.
I'm in the middle of it now.
It's pretty good.
But they said that was one of Pablos things like Pablo Escobar was like,
I'm going to put coke back into cold
calls.
Coco.
Well,
you know,
Coca Cola still uses cocaine for flavoring.
Yeah.
They still use coca leaves.
They're like one of the biggest producers of medical cocaine.
The same company that takes the coca leaves,
they extract the cocaine out of it,
use whatever flavor that makes.
That's why Coca Cola tastes better than Pepsi.
I had medical cocaine,
I had liquid cocaine.
Um,
I cut my retina like playing ball and end it is pain.
Like you would not,
you know,
it's,
it's as painful as it sounds and apparently that's what the treatment is.
Like he gave me this eyedrop and the pain went away instantly.
I'm like,
what was that?
He said cocaine.
I was like,
oh can I,
and he said,
no,
we don't prescribe it.
You got to come in and we put the drop in your eye.
But yeah,
it was,
and it was one of the,
you know how you go to the doctor when you're hurt and you want it to stop
hurting right away.
It did.
Like it was one of those rare times when you go to the doctor like Yep,
that stopped the pain instantly.
Thank you doc.
But that's what,
that's what they use it.
I'm sure it has other uses uses,
but yeah,
when I had my nose fixed,
they put light of keen in there,
which is like the gay cousin of cocaine.
Cocaine's cocaine's less talented brother
and uh,
it tastes horrible.
It tastes fucking,
but it numbs everything up.
But all it does is now everything up.
You don't get,
you don't get sick,
but you do get this weird jittery feeling.
Like I went out that night,
I went to dinner and uh,
I tried to eat,
I just,
I couldn't eat.
It was like my appetite was all fucked up and I was all,
I'm,
I realize like,
Oh I guess this is like the effects of that light king shit cause they'd been
squirting up my nose and you know,
it's weird with drugs what people like,
you know,
like,
like I,
I went through a surgery and they gave me that morphine drip like Ooh yeah I got
one bus and some people love it.
And I was like,
this is like,
it would put me to sleep.
But
I had no desire to,
to feel like that.
Whereas if you're a heroin addict,
you want to feel like that all the time.
Maybe I can be a heroin addict then because I fucking loved it man.
I had my ACL reconstructed.
You'd go more that way I think.
Cause you're naturally so you're naturally a high energy like active person.
So yes.
So your high was probably be a slow down whereas I'm more,
you know,
I'm naturally slow laid back so my high was more up.
I think that's why I took the pot so well this is pot like gave me a chance to
slow down and look at things.
I always felt like most of my life was always like,
oh just fucking go just and then can away get out of your own way.
Cause like the momentum of all the Shit I had done before was always like
knocking on my door and my keep moving.
No,
no time for introspective thinking.
No time for objectivity,
just fucking run.
And if you get success,
good.
That success justifies all this behavior and motion.
So keep going.
And Pot was the first thing that made me go,
oh,
what am I doing?
Like what am,
why am I doing this?
Why,
why,
why?
What is the purpose of all of this?
What is,
what is my path?
Where,
what,
what do,
what makes me happy?
What do I want to do?
What?
What makes me unhappy?
How do I stop doing that?
You know,
like made me think about things in a way,
but when I had my ACL reconstructed the first one,
the second one,
they didn't do shit.
The second one was so easy.
I had to,
and I tell everybody if you have a chance,
um,
then they offer you a,
that is two different types of,
there's a,
there's three different types of use.
They sometimes use hamstring,
which was really rough and a lot of rehab.
They,
Terry,
they cut a chunk of your hamstring and it takes a long time for that to come
back.
And some people,
they don't feel like it ever is 100% and they put that and they use that as a
tendon.
But I had the Patella tendon graft,
they take a piece of bone out of your shin and a piece of bone out of your knee
cap and then they slice the Patella tendon and it's connected with these two
pieces of bone and the Patella 10 is a very thick,
wide tendon and they use that as a replacement for your ACL.
I had that done in my left knee,
and that's the one that did the a morphine drip.
The right knee,
they used a cadaver.
They use an achilles tendon,
so it's much thicker than an ACL and it's like a 150% stronger and they use
that.
They screw that in place.
I went to a party five days later,
I was walking around without crutches.
I was like,
this is crazy.
It was so much better.
But the first one,
the Patella tendon was like fire was gone through my veins.
It was like I would get up off the couch and uh,
I didn't like take pain pills.
I hated the way those made me feel.
I don't remember what it was,
percocets or Vicodins,
I don't remember which one it was,
but I remember I sold them to this due to the pool hall because I was like,
these are fucking bullshit.
I hate that.
I'd rather be in pain than be that stupid.
Yeah.
But the trip at the hospital was like being a,
it was like having your balls cradled by angels.
It was just like you were being hugged by God.
It was like the world was just giving you this big warm hug.
It's like everything's gonna be fine.
I was on this machine that constantly straightened my leg and bent.
It is like this constant motion machine because they're trying to keep your leg
from going stiff after they,
you know,
fucking chisel into it and start script putting screws in and all that.
So this machine is going
and I'm going click
and I'm just melting into this fucking bed.
And the last time I had that feeling was,
uh,
in the early,
maybe the late nineties,
I guess it was.
It must've been the late nineties.
Cause I,
I,
uh,
I remember I lived out here and I got ahold of some of the real nyquil before
they took that shit off the market.
The alcohol with the coding in it.
Yeah.
Oh God.
It was 25 proof with coding or something.
Yeah,
it was so good.
It was so good.
Forgot you had a cold.
I knew a comic,
you said drink that shit of people used to drink it.
He used to get bottles of it.
Dill,
the the people that worked at the Comedy Club at Rascals in New Jersey.
I go to rascals.
You'd have to bring bottles of fucking Nyquil and they would always just talk
about it.
Yeah.
He fucking wants bottles of Nyquil.
It just drinks nyquil.
It goes into his hotel room and drinks.
NYQUIL.
Yeah.
My knees have no cartilage like that's just beat up.
So when they hurt my doctor's like,
yeah,
we're going to replace them.
We just wait.
Don't,
don't,
don't listen.
If that's all it is is just cartilage.
You got to get stem cells.
Stem cell shots.
Oh my God,
Dude.
It's the greatest thing of all time.
They actually regenerate tissue.
They can regenerate meniscus,
regenerate cartilage and bone on bone situations.
I'll hook you up with his doctor.
I'll go get you connected to him there.
It's just over the last couple of years they're doing these things.
They're having a miraculous results with stem cells dies and someone was,
someone online complained to me on Twitter though.
They're good.
Go load of people can't afford themselves.
What do you want me to not talk about it?
Should I not talk about how awesome it is because people can't afford it.
I mean that's the way our,
you know,
medicine is,
but yeah,
I get it.
It's annoying to you that you can't afford it,
but I'm not going to not talk.
I had it in my shoulder.
I had that stem cell shot in my shoulder.
I was like probably a couple months away from surgery.
I was like,
just trying to figure out when I could schedule it because just it was so
annoying.
Every time I'd work out it'd be in pain for a few days and then I would do it
again and ice it and all this different shit and I was like,
I'm going to have to fucking bite the bullet and get this thing fixed.
One stem cell shot,
boom.
Within two weeks it feels a hundred percent better,
but other than a month it felt better than I've felt in a year.
And now it's like,
I mean occasionally it's,
it's sore.
Like yesterday I lifted and I lifted this morning and he's kind of a little
sore,
but nothing to complain about.
No big deal.
It's funny when you're talking about how they take part of the shin bone and the
other bone to put it.
Oh,
when doctors do shit like that,
I'm like,
how smart are you?
You know what I mean like that,
that like,
wow,
you can actually do that.
You know,
like I shattered my wrist and the doc,
I got to know the doctor who first I could crash.
Yeah,
I know it on a race track.
Not,
oh,
not ordinary circumstance,
but I was talking to the doctor and you know,
and we become friends over time.
We,
I fuck with him about it.
He fucks with me.
Like when he,
when he did the surgery and he said he'll do it again.
I'm like,
well,
you couldn't get shit right the first time.
And he's like,
well,
if you hadn't fucked it up so bad,
you know,
it's like that kind of,
but,
but sometimes I just looked at him like,
how smart are you?
Could you just put bodies back together?
His shit is amazing.
He's like,
well you,
I tell fucking Dick joke,
you go inside the human body and repair it.
That's certainly amazing.
Different kinds of smart.
How about that Ben Carson Guy,
that guy that runs for president,
how was a neurosurgeon that he fixed conjoined twins at the head and yet you'd
listened to him talk,
now you talk about the disconnect that I honestly,
it's not like Herman Cain cause obviously I make fun of all these guys and the
black Republican is always going to be hilarious because it's like everyone else
knows,
nobody told you.
But to be that smart and yet when you listen to some of his political stuff,
you're like,
how does that work?
I don't understand that because you're in neurosis and you're not just a
neurosurgeon.
Like you worked your way up from nowhere.
It wasn't like you were born into,
you know,
a silver spoon in your mouth or whatever light.
So yeah,
I don't,
I don't understand Ben Carson at all.
Well,
it's hard when you start,
when he starts talking about religion,
when he starts talking about,
uh,
the Big Bang and evolution is a myth and the big bang is bullshit.
Like he doesn't believe in evolution,
right?
He mean he might think the earth is 10,000 years old.
He had been one of those guys.
Yeah.
He's got some really wacky ideas,
but when it comes to fixing a brain,
he knows what the fuck to do.
Yeah.
And but that's what I mean.
Like how do you put those two together like in the course of learning to fix a
brain,
didn't they teach you any other science?
Wasn't there any other science classes you went to when you doesn't buy it?
Not to buy it?
I don't know,
man.
Maybe it's,
maybe it's like the Hubris that you have to have to be so confident that you
could fix conjoined twins.
Cause apparently conjoined twins at the head is like one of the most dangerous.
Oh absolutely.
It took more than 20 hours.
They brought in surgeons from all over the world to assist him,
but he figured out a way to,
they shared one artery between like a major artery between the two brains and he
figured out a way to channel it and make it work.
So that's two votes he's going to get.
He's ahead of Trump now.
I know.
That's what's really crazy and the most recent polls,
he's ahead of Trump.
That's because this is the,
this is the reality show portion
and then next year they get to the real election.
You know what I mean?
Next years when they're next to you is when the real candidates,
do you think that's why Trump is so gung ho already knows it's bullshit.
I know Trump's going to sell books and get a TV show or whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like this is all publicity for Trump.
My theory.
Yeah.
My theory is that around December or January,
Trump comes up with a way to back out like,
I don't want to work with these politicians are,
this is bull.
You know what I mean?
He comes up with something like that.
Like when I was running for governor and he backs out of it and then he rides
the wave of the publicity.
He might be right or president Trump,
what have you fucking wins?
What if he gets in there?
I mean,
would that be the biggest,
I just can't see it happening.
Why not?
Because for one thing,
he knows nothing about policy or how government works or you know,
but how hard is that to learn?
Oh,
it's very hard on them on that level.
Even like even Barack Obama who went in knowing it,
I think like his first two years in office was an education.
Because I think you,
when you really find out how hard it is to make this work and to get these
people to work together and to get anything done,
you know what I mean?
Like I think,
I think he learned a lot about like how to try to make politics work.
How did you get anything done?
And Trump,
Trump is more like,
like Schwartz Nigga,
when Schwarzenegger thought he was going to go in and call the legislature girly
men and be the terminator and they were like Fuck Outta here.
Like he had like,
he got slapped,
you know,
and it would be the same thing with Trump.
They'd be,
what do you mean you're fired?
Shut up.
You know,
this is being,
that Trump would probably make a big deal out of explaining where all these
bottlenecks are.
He'll probably make a big deal about explaining to the public,
doing press conferences and not playing ball.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
can rich,
but there's no,
that's no secret though.
Everyone knows that,
you know,
we all know about party,
and we,
you know,
and,
and to get in with all the back door deals and stuff like that,
like you got,
you know,
you got to have some serious backing.
You know,
like he has a lot of money,
but he doesn't have Koch brothers money or what's that guy who owns the casinos
in Vegas?
Um,
I,
I don't even know his name.
He owns a Venetian and stuff like,
you know,
I don't want to say his name sounds like candy man.
You want to say that's too much money or these or,
or you know,
on the Democrat side they have some people,
I mean you got,
you know,
Spielberg and Geffin and all of that.
Like Trump has money,
he doesn't have their money,
nor does he have their influence.
He does.
He doesn't have their influence when it comes to the media and when it comes to
everything
else involved.
You know,
what's annoying to me,
how many women that want to vote for Hillary just because she's a woman and I'd
like to know how much shady shit is going on with her.
Like I've had these conversations like I'll vote for,
I want a woman in office,
Mike,
but do you under,
do you know how shady she is?
Do you know that when she was a criminal lawyer,
she,
uh,
she was a defense lawyer.
She got some guy off for raping a kid.
There was like some,
there's like a video or a recording of her joking around about it from like the
1980s or whatever the fuck it was when,
when this happened,
if you're going to be a politician,
your bed,
you know what I mean?
Like you're,
you're like,
but even before she was a politician,
the way either email and even then she was in it because bill has been in it
from the beginning.
Yeah.
The thing I,
the thing I like about Hillary is she knows how the game's played.
Like she has experienced and she's very smart.
So I,
I give her that.
Is she per,
I don't think she's perfect.
I think she's the best of them.
Of the ones who run it.
I think she's the best.
She scares me.
And the thing about Bernie Sanders,
although I like a lot of what he says,
it's not going to get done.
Like what,
what particular,
what about the taxes?
He talks crazy about tax,
about 12 fucking shit out of Richmond.
Well he wants to do,
he wants to do what some other countries do with the government provides a lot
more services,
but it's paid for by a lot more taxes.
Yeah.
And so,
so now you're going to have to somehow get that rich 1% that ain't paying to
suddenly be willing to pay and to make college free.
Sounds good.
But now you're talking about chain.
See it.
When you start talking about changing an entire system,
when you talk about cutting money out of defense to pay for things.
Yeah,
it sounds great.
But the problem is this.
This has been this deaf military industrial defense complex business that said
like how many military bases that we have where it's just welfare for the town.
They don't need the base,
but the base is there cause the base employees,
everyone in the town and if you shut down to base,
the town goes broke.
I mean that's true all across America.
And then you have an,
the congressmen from that town will fight to the death like that.
There's a a naval base in West Virginia.
What's in the ocean?
There's no ocean.
But they had this congressmen,
I forget his name,
but he was like,
that was his thing.
He was that guy.
And he's like,
I'm getting these jobs and this money to my district.
You know what I mean?
So,
so when you get a Bernie Sanders,
when you get someone who's talking about,
I'm going to change the whole system.
And I think this was a thing with Barack when Barack Obama ran initially and it
was about hope and change and a bunch of young people college age got on board
and they wanted everything to change and it was great and I think he really
meant
it.
And then he got there and it was like,
oh,
this ain't going to get done.
Because he,
when he got there and he had a democratic congress,
like if there was any chance of him doing it,
it was when he had the,
the president and the Congress from the same party.
And even then congress was like,
well no,
we ain't changing that shit.
You know,
we're not going to mess with that.
It's like they say,
moving to the United States is like turning an aircraft carrier.
You know,
it,
it turns,
but it takes a long time.
That's the one thing I really love about Bernie Sanders,
the idea of free college.
I think the idea that these kids come out of college and they're,
oh hundreds of thousands of dollars in student loans and they're fucked.
And then I just drives me crazy.
It makes so much sense that you're,
you're almost baffled that why we don't do it.
There was one state,
and I want to say it was Iowa one say it was Iowa and,
and I only know about this because a friend of mine,
her kid was in school at the time and she was divorced and her husband lived
there and,
but they had this deal.
They said the first 10 cents of every tax dollar goes to the schools and you
can't mess with that.
You can't change it.
You can't be.
And what they noticed,
they didn't plan it,
but about seven,
eight years later,
their jail population started dropping.
Wow.
Yeah.
But you know,
I could have kids go to school,
they don't go to jail,
you know,
and you look at the cost of putting a guy in jail for one year versus putting
them in college for a year.
It just makes so much more sense.
Not to mention the fact that it how,
how is an educated populace bad other than the fact you can't control it.
That's the only negative to,
to educating people.
You can't control them.
Well that,
and if you do have an educated populace that's in debt,
they're going to have to work three and a have to work and they're going to have
to keep your fucking mouth shut and stay inside the boundaries of the system.
But
that's what,
but I'm talking about if you do away with the debt so that more people can go to
college.
Like in other words,
the more people that go to college,
the better a country we are.
And yet they,
they literally fight against,
you know,
and,
and it's always funny when you see people fight against their best interest,
you know,
like why don't think it is there
best interest because they make money off of the fact that college,
I mean,
college education,
this country subsidized.
I mean,
neither.
One of the reasons why it's so expensive is because the government is involved,
the governments involved in all these loans and there's money in that.
And whenever you have a tremendous amount of money that's being generated by
anything,
whether it's college or law enforcement or the drug war,
you become,
it becomes an industry.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
But you're talking about the military,
like shutting down those bases.
The same thing would would happen if you figured out a way to pay for college is
through tax dollars.
There would be,
without a doubt,
some people would lose their jobs,
lose their gigs.
But what I what I mean,
yeah.
Is
that is the overall,
in other words,
the overall health of the nation,
like if any way better,
smarter,
yeah,
we're,
we're
better off.
The one thing we look,
if you want to make the nation strong,
make less losers.
It's real simple.
I mean that's the number one argument for cleaning up all these impoverished
areas in our country,
right?
All these like we look at what Baltimore,
I had this Guy Michael Wood on this podcast that was a former cop in Baltimore
and he,
they,
when they were there,
when he was working there,
they found some papers from the 1970s that showed all the crime areas and all
the tactics they were using and he's like,
we're fucking doing the same shit they were doing in the 1970s.
We're spinning our wheels.
What if you want to fix that area?
Like concentrating resources on that area and,
and,
and figuring out a way to solve this,
uh,
this poverty cycle that just keeps going on and crime cycle that just keeps
going on.
Like you will have less losers,
you'll have less people that you have to prosecute.
You're talking about education because education and opportunity don't exist.
I mean that is,
that is the one thing about the cycle of poverty that I think a lot of people
can't understand.
It's like,
you know,
we'll get it.
Just get a job.
Like we'll know you,
you don't have that.
You know,
and when you go to school and your books are,
are eight years old,
you know,
like when you say like this generation grew up with the Internet,
but a lot of kids don't,
you know,
a lot of kids,
like that's where the separation is where you have an iPad when you were in
school or did you have an eight year old textbook and then you get to the
college level.
Now you're supposed to compete with the kid who had the IPAD,
you know,
it,
the whole system.
Yeah.
And,
and it,
it's,
it's one of those things that it just makes sense to do something,
you know,
it's,
it's like guns.
It's like
we have to admit that,
okay,
we got to do something like that.
That's the first thing before we do anything,
let's just admit we have to do something because whatever we're doing isn't
working.
And then once we realized we have to do something,
then figure out what to do.
But instead we're,
we're always us versus them.
So it's like,
you know,
either no guns at all or,
or just carry your AK to a grocery store.
Like I'm sure there's somewhere in between those two that works.
And,
and we have become a nation that has become so divided on every issue.
And sometimes when it's no reason to be divided other than the other side said
it and it just keeps anything from getting done.
I don't know.
I don't know what this country is going to be in 50 years.
You know,
it's going to be very different because we're all these complications that we
have right now,
all the problems that we have right now,
they're going to be accelerated.
They're going to be accelerated when the growth of the population,
when more and more people around it's going to,
there's going to be more and more problems.
And then there's going to be all these technological issues.
There's going to be cyber crime is,
it's gonna be,
it's gonna be really difficult to keep money in your bank account.
People are just going to be stealing from bank accounts
left and right.
You're going to have virtual reality.
You're going to have people escaping reality in all sorts of ways that they're
not really doing yet.
And that's going to be just as addictive as crack.
Yeah.
It was going to be people that are just dropping out of society and living in
the headset.
I'm going to put on virtual reality goggles,
you know,
or we're going to,
or people are going to be figured out how to use it and how to make society
work,
you know better or educate people more or,
or allow for communication.
You know what I mean?
When you talk about these kids who grew up with the Internet and other thing
knew growing up is there growing up globally,
they have friends in Europe and shit like that,
like that communicate with people from other countries all the time.
And you,
you learn so much.
Like there's so much cult,
more culturally savvy because of that.
Then so,
eh,
it's one of those things,
it's like we can become much better or much worse.
And I don't really know.
Sometimes I think,
well,
we're going to be better than some shit happens you like,
wow,
we can't be trusted with anything,
you know,
so I don't know.
Uh,
I don't know what's going to happen.
And you know,
and that's where you have,
like when you have Trump,
you know,
honestly,
when you have this visit viable presidential candidate saying what?
We're going to build a war wall between here and Mexico cause name on rapists
and it put my name on it.
You're like,
okay.
No.
Like,
that's no,
you know,
so,
well that's like some new land and Stalin type shit putting his name on it.
Yeah.
And yet yet you have a percentage of the Polish population who honestly believes
that,
you know what I mean?
Like we still have what 40% of the Republicans in the south or whatever that's
still believe Barack Obama's a Muslim undercover.
He's not sorry,
Jill,
I didn't mean to ruin else.
I didn't mean to ruin it for you.
We're out of time.
Dude.
We ran out of time,
man,
hit that.
We hit the three hour mark.
Bam.
This was amazing.
It was fun to do it again.
Do it again.
Thank you.
You're in town all the time,
right?
Thank you.
Anytime.
And he's a gentlemen,
a Alonzo voting on Twitter,
a website,
Alonzo boden.com that's crazy.
How do we remember that?
I don't know.
Dod,
Thank you brother.
And your podcast is paying is paying attention.
Sinai iTunes on jazz.
All that glorious.
We did it,
man.
Thank you,
sir.
We did it.
Thank you,
brother.
All right.
See you guys soon.
Later.
Okay.
Yeah.